e
good
morning welcome to Jael car looks like
is that better yes okay you can hear me
all
right oh let's see who's
here Senator Chanley Senator Ward
Senator
Whitley Senator gray is sitting in for
Senator Lang who can't make
it and representative duet here sitting
Andis
here and there's representative Schmidt
okay we don't need any house
alternates good morning
morning okay the minutes of the previous
and I'll
second and a second is there any
discussion of the meeting minutes of the
previous
meeting all right we have a motion to
approve all in favor I
opposed thank
you the consent agenda does anyone have
anything they want to remove from the
consent agenda
discussion those in favor I
all right regular
agenda all right the first on the
regular agenda actually I think
representative L has s has suggested
that we take up the solid waste program
rules first and she has a motion
okay uh thank you I would um I would
move a preliminary objection on um the
rule FP 2024 74 four
second do you wish to speak to your
motion uh yes thank you madam chair we
have received uh very very large amount
of testimony raising questions with this
rule uh there are questions that were
raised both about the specifics and how
it relates to the safety that's done not
just in this country but around the
world um there's a question of how it
relates to the existing rules as well we
have also heard questions about the
process and which voices have been heard
how it's been recognized and uh
basically how public input has or has
not been listened to so I believe that
there needs to be some more work to make
sure that all of the concerned voices
are heard and that we understand exactly
what this rural change will mean not
just for our landfills but for the
people of New Hampshire um and so more
specifically um we can object BEC about
on the condition of this being contrary
to the public interest about not being
responsive to the public need uh we have
received a decent amount of testimony
that suggests that
um and I'm not sure if I if I need to
run through all the different issues on
the preliminary objection you need to
explain the reasons for the preliminary
objection and that's it okay thank
you I'd like to comment that the
um there was vast amounts of content of
comment and the explanations on how it
was addressed
are extremely technical and I it didn't
seem to me that the many of the
commenters who came back and complained
about the rule really understood what
the
U um what the what the how the comments
were actually addressed yeah there's
also the issue that the these rules are
much more protective than the existing
rules which have been extended for as
long as we're in rul making and are what
is now now currently being used to
evaluate I believe it's two
landfill
um landfill
applications and if we drag this out any
much further it's possible that the
landfills in question might be approved
on the 10-year-old rules rather than the
new rules which are more protective and
I don't believe that's what anybody
wants so I would I'm going to support
the objection and hope the agency can
come back with some more accessible
information Senator Greg um my only
question is from to the staff is if
there is anything else we need to wave
any of the deadlines or anything to
accomplish this no the preliminary
objection creates a 45-day period for
the agency to respond and after that
joker has a 50-day period to to respond
to that yes but I s the rules but after
some discussions with the with other
people I think it's it's likely that
they would be able to come back with
some answers for our December meeting
and we could give it a fair shot and
that will also give give us a chance to
read a bit more of the
testimony any other
comments just to be clear on the
objection so you are objecting um
according to public interest under Jael
car 4030 1 A2 and 40301
G uh yes and are you also objecting
under the legislative intent issue
surrounding the purpose statement yes I
am
okay I'd like to concur with
representative Leon's remarks and the
chairs as well mam chair okay anyone
else representative Whitley oh Senator
Whitley excuse
me um thank you madam chair I'm
wondering if the committee wanted to
hear from members of the public who were
here I know this is an issue that people
care deeply about and I wonder if we
wanted to
hear the members of the public have
submitted large quantities of written
testimony that I don't believe much of
the committee has actually had a chance
to digest yet and we will if necessary
we'll talk to other people on the uh um
at the at the meeting when the agency
has their response we have heard enough
of the public testimony to be concerned
about the rules and that's why we're
were
objecting mam chair is there written
testimony been submitted by any of the
parties that are coming here today yes
you have have some right there in front
of you yes so um five over 500 pages of
testimony were submitted to our office I
have reviewed those I have some here on
in my stack that I just received today
at before the meeting which have not
been reviewed but they will be added to
to the the file and added to your
meeting packets online thank
you anyone else have questions
comments in that case the motion is to
preliminarily object to
the uh landfill
rules the the 800 rules
and those in favor I I
opposed okay thank you very much and I'm
looking forward to getting a response
agency
okay all
education uh before we hear from the
staff on this I want to make it
perfectly clear that this is not a
public hearing we have received again
vast quantities of public testimony
which has been considered by both the
Education and I also noticed that on the
more recent submissions they were first
of all based
significantly on old versions of the
rules and they didn't reflect the
changes that had been made in response
to the first round of
comments um so I'm going going to say
that we don't need to hear duplicative
testimony we had over an hour of it a
month ago and I am not the least bit
interested in hearing the same things
over and over again except as the Board
of Education States how they changed the
rule in response to said
comments and so yes Senator gray uh I
also want to make sure that the public
knows that if there objection is to the
RSA and the rules accurately reflect
what is in the RSA that is not something
that this committee can do anything
about thank you yes I was getting on to
the next point which is we are not a
policy committee we can only observe the
policy as set in the statute and see how
the rules follow the statute if the if
the rules violate the statute that's
something we will talk about if they
support the statute but you but the
public has concerns with parts or all of
the statute that's not something we can
do anything with so we
and all right any other representative
Roa yes thank you Madame chair I also
like to say that if the rules violate
the statute or indicate the lack of
legislative intent those are things that
we would want to hear
about right but um if if they're
following the statute that's all we can
we can enforce we can't object to a rule
because we don't like the policy that
the legislature has adopted agree much
as we would like to sometimes but we
can't Madam chair yes yeah it's more
than just the statute we can object to
if the rules are contrary to public
interest I want to be clear about that
it's contrary to legislative intent and
contrary to the public interest PR so it
it it it it's a little broader than just
the statute well yes but
uh in in from some of the comments I was
getting the impression that there is a
policy dispute and that is not something
we should be taking up all right
so so we are looking at uh proposal 2024
41 this is called been called the first
half of the 306s it includes Ed
30601 to Ed
30626 this includes the minimum
standards for public school approval and
I have no substantive comments on this
rule on October 29th um the legislative
oversight Committee of Education
Improvement and Assessment program voted
4 to two to recommend support of this
proposal with the contingency that the
term educator as defined is change to
the definition from RSA 21 n d oh sorry
21 in8
DC that definition of educator is um
educator means teacher or certified par
professional um I am looking at an
amended conditional approval request
from the Department that includes that
change as recommended by the oversight
committee and so I have no further
you does the depart does the Board of
Education have a comment that they we
need to
hear no
okay thank you Representatives Miler and
luno have some concerns about the
process and we'll give them a couple of
minutes
Madam chair would you like me to go over
also
um so we can take them
together I believe that this is relative
to both of them so we'll they're there
let them finish and then uh that we'll
42 thank you madam chair for the record
I'm representative Mel Meer marac County
District 9 representing the towns of
Hopkin
and Bo I come before you today to oppose
the process for the development of the
306 education rules that are before you
today I have been involved in New
Hampshire education policym for over 30
years I have served as the executive
director of Na New Hampshire for 21
years and for 12 years on the house
education committee as a ranking them
and chair I will address four concerns
one the historic role of the department
has played in the education policy and
Rule making two the contracted Services
of developing the proposed 306 rules
three the role of HB
1622 demanding the recog recognition of
Citizen input in rule making and for HB
1163 the role of the legislative
oversight committee those are the four
areas I want to address first the
Department of Education has historically
actively engaged the education community
in the development of rules and policy
impacting students they have led the
engagement of members of school boards
administrators and teachers in seeking
their input these are the professionals
that work day-to-day on implementing the
standards and the rules governing
education of our students for example
the policies related to teacher
evaluation and the educator ethics and
code of conduct actively brought
together by the department practitioners
in the field this historic role of
directly enlisting those in the field
did not happen in this current process
of the 306 rules second the granting of
the
$75,000 contract to the National Center
for Competency Based learning violated
the historic engagement of school of the
school Community I have deep respect for
for the president of the
ncbl for his commitment to New Hampshire
education but the model used was flawed
he gathered a few representatives of the
education leadership and created a doc
initial document he then conducted a
series of events across the street
trying to share components of the draft
document the intent of the session was
to seek Community input but input never
was achieved I attended three sessions
there was an overview of the draft
document the document was not shared so
that the attendant the attendees did not
have an opportunity to provide input or
reaction most of those attending were
School Personnel the result of was
frustration because they lacked the
importance of the work being done the
important an opportunity for Vital input
was lost there was an 11th Hour attempt
to include some school advocates in the
review but it was a little little too
late and little the timing was wrong
third the last session of the
legislature demonstrated its commitment
to Citizen input on rule making both the
Senate and the house overrode the
governor's veto of HB
1622 in case you forgot what that action
was Let me refresh your
memory this is the quote from that law
quote item e a report of public comments
received on the rule shall be created
the report shall indicate how the
comment was incorporated into the final
rule if the comment was not incorporated
into the final rule the agency shall
provide a detailed explanation that
includes the facts data interpretation
and policy choices that justified why
the adopting agency did not not amend
the rules because of the flawed input
process as I noted above Christine
Downey who is here today to present her
concerns about the process she's an an
educator out of Goan she took it upon
herself to initiate an independent 306
review process you have received a
summary of her two-year work in
involving over 200 educated
practitioners her work represents the
historic role the department should have
played at the outset of the ru of the
process she has made multiple pre
presentations to the State Board of
Education she has been an advocate
representing the interests of those who
will Implement those rules when the
commissioner of Education was asked at
the legislative oversight session what
was the status of Dr Downey's work his
response was quote thank you for her
work end quote when pressed by a member
of the Comm committee he could not site
anywhere in the proposed document where
the Downing work was represented or
included fourth and finally the
education legislative oversight
committee's role has been totally
dismissed by the department again there
was clear legislative intent on the role
of the oversight Committee in in
reviewing and recommending
rules in an earlier session and in an
earlier session uh we adopted HB
1163 let me State what that says quote
review and make recommendations relating
to academic standards under the
consideration of the State Board of
Education pursuant to RSA 93e col
2-a and this is the new language and
minimum standards for public school
approval under the consideration by the
State Board of Education pursuant to 93
the oversight committee held five
sessions because of the multiple drafts
it was difficult for them to receive the
final version the committee's
Legislative Assistant produced a side
by-side version the department presented
thems just one time to the committee in
those five sessions in the middle of
that session the department realized
that the committee had the wrong version
of the document and further they did not
provide the committee with the deart
Department reference documents that they
were working from there was confusion
subsequently the chair of the committee
met with commissioner seeking answers to
the question he had the committee
members had no further opportunity to
get answers to the questions they had
the lack of respect by the department
for the legislative process is a clear
violation of the legislative oversight
mandate for these four reasons I object
to the rules
the rules are very important and they
need revision the current rules have
established a sound educational system
for our students we we have continued to
rank number within the top five
nationally because of these rules these
rules have always included active
engagement of educational Personnel
finally how this committee deals with
the objections to those that are before
you is key to the president that you
will make in considering the future
rules coming before you clearly I
believe that the department has violated
its historic role it's intent of
1622 and HP
1163 no State Department is exempt from
the role of the legislature thank you
Madame chairman for allowing me to
express my
views thank you representative luno do
you have a
few thank thank you Madam chair and I'll
um I'll U uh streamline my uh my
comments as representative Myer has has
covered quite a bit of it uh for the
record my name is Dave luno uh
representing the people of Marmont
County District 9ine uh which uh which
include the towns of Hopkinson and boow
but uh but as we all know we all have
statewide responsibilities so all
Granite Staters are U are in our in our
interest I want to quickly go through
what the uh what the legislative
oversight um uh committee did so the uh
the committee's actually established an
RSA 193 C8 UHA and uh and it does have
authority to uh review and
recommend uh any proposed rules before
uh before those rules are approved by
the State Board of Education uh and as
representative Miler uh said that
Authority was expanded uh just this
summer when the governor signed House
Bill 1163 to not only include academic
standards but also the minimum standards
for school um School approval um we um
the the the committee actually started
its work back uh back in March 2023 with
respect to the proposed standards and uh
and reviewing what the committee's U uh
statutory Authority is over um over Rec
uh reviewing and recommending such um uh
proposed changes to uh to the rules um
uh it met um uh it met twice actually in
where um where much of the discussion in
its second meeting was largely talked
talking about the uh the process for uh
for it was actually a road show the
process for public uh public input um uh
beginning with uh uh I think a forum uh
at Campbell High School and going to
conquer and going to B where uh where I
attended along with representative Myer
and about uh excuse me 20 other uh 20
other people um a year went went by
after after that meeting uh before the
committee next met um uh in the summer
of two of 2024 where members of the uh
accountability and legislative oversight
committee received a 46-page proposal of
changes to what's known as the front
half of the rules over nearly two hours
the committee barely got through the
first two pages of definitions and
general discussion was directed to
leaving the rules as is without any
changes at all excuse me what was the
date the preliminary that that
was that was on June 26 2024 all right
so so you met shortly after the
preliminary uh initial proposal was
issued corre correct is that correct
correct okay thank you I just want to
make the timeline straight right right
so I I believe the preliminary proposal
I don't have it in front of me may have
been dated February 2024 so
um it was issued to the public in in
June okay in in that so so that that was
undoubtedly in work for quite a while
that lines up thank you y y please
continue so two months later on August
22nd 2024 the commissioner along with um
the education Department's rule
administrator Julie Shay testified
before the committee during questioning
it was made clear by m that the
committee was provided with the
incorrect draft of the propos osed rules
and you can actually find that at uh 25
minutes 45 seconds into the um into the
meeting uh during the meeting the
commissioner avoided direct questions of
why the proposed rules specifically 22
and 23 were not considered to be changes
to academic standards the committee met
again October 17th
2024 uh again uh commissioner edbl and
miss Shay returned to the committee to
present the back half of the proposed
rule changes changes that clearly would
impact the academic standards meaning
what students should know at certain
grade levels in fact the the proposed
changes scrapped existing rules
pertinent to curriculum instruction and
assessment in each of the contact areas
required under statute RSA 193 e2a and
instead replace those rules with
references to curriculum Frameworks some
dating back more than two decades the
committee was not provided with nor did
it conduct any review of the referenced
curriculum Frameworks that apparently
include academic
standards um shortly thereafter on
October 21st 2024 the committee reviewed
the proposed rules with respect to the
2018 report from The Joint legislative
oversight committee on costing of
inadequate education and uh I believe
representative Myer served on um uh on
that uh that committee um in that report
that legislative committee issued a
finding that the student student teacher
ratio quote necessary to provide the
opportunity for an adequate education in
New Hampshire is 25 to1 in K2 and 30 to1
in grades 3- 12 this most recent
legislative intent is clearly in
Conflict to the proposed rules which
eliminate maximum class siiz standards
members uh had many questions specific
to the proposed rules both front and
back however the department was a
no-show at that meeting on October 29th
2024 so now we're just a week after that
last meeting the committee held a final
meeting to get our questions answered I
spoke with the chair before the meeting
and he told me that he had a private
meeting with the commissioner and that
his questions had been answered so I
asked the chair who's going to answer my
questions and his response was that the
Department of Education would have
someone present at that final meeting
that day to answer questions from the
committee
members however nobody from the
education department Department showed
up Department was not there to answer
questions from the committee members and
I feel that not only failed me but
failed the thousands of constituents who
I represent in the legislature and for
that matter more than a million grandet
Staters who we all represent in summary
the Department of Education has not
provided members of the legislative
oversight committee with the correct
complete and accurate documents or
answers to questions necessary for the
committee to do it its job per the
statute and represent our constituents
and the videos of the meeting serve as
you
yes we have a chair now in
are we have a chair in the egress area
if if the lady could move over to the
table uh if she needs that or something
but uh we we do need to keep that aisle
uh open so that if there is a problem
it and and and we we would like to
accommodate you to make sure that if you
need your your foot up or whatever that
we can do that but just you know want to
make sure that that egress is available
Senator thank you for your input is
please I would just like to clarify that
HB 1622 does not go into effect until
December 9th the public summary com uh
comment report that the education
department filed with the office of os
statute yes oh thank you that's good to
know uh thank you madam chair I'm Drew
Klein I'm chairman of the State Board of
Education
and Julie Shay administrative rules
coordinator for the Department of
Education Elizabeth Brown I'm Council
Department I thank you thank you for the
opportunity to respond the first point I
just want to get out of the way because
it keeps coming up is that the rules and
eliminate um classroom sizes that's not
true that's never been true um
the current rules as you see and 30614
and
30612 keep uh in response to public
comment in response to the hearings and
the input from Educators that you just
heard didn't happen which actually did
happen we
incorporated the current class size
limits into the rules so those do not
change
and that just has to be clear
because we keep seeing this uh
misinformation this this
disinformation um circulated and it's
not true um we in the conversation about
class size rules in the initial proposal
we opened it up to conversation and I
made very clear in Board of Education
meetings that we were looking at ways to
give districts some flexibility to
respond to to parents and respond to the
post
pandemic and think about what
constitutes a classroom and how they
might configure that and so we thought
maybe we could do ratios of Educators to
students and we floated that idea and
the feedback we got was um we really
feel safer if you mandate that we have
class siiz caps so we inated the
existing class- siiz caps into the rule
and they are still there um would could
you uh point us to where they're showing
on the so 306
.14
30614 they are in there page 12 of the
amended conditional approval request
page 12 yes all right and they've been
in there for a long time um so it's it's
simply not
true that we eliminated the class siiz
caps
um secondly uh this was the
longest rulemaking process uh to my
knowledge in State Board of Education
history it went on for um depending on
where you start the process three plus
years with the Contracting and the um
hearings and the input Fred Bon's
organization that was contracted to
begin this process collected input in
the draft process from
Educators when we
began
the um official rule making
process it we went through um a very
extensive um some people have derided it
as a road show I don't know why you
would deride that we went we did 13
listening sessions around the state that
has never happened before in the history
of board education
rulemaking we did 13 listening sessions
going to public schools around the
state advertised
noticed to get public input from the
public and from Educators and from you
know all School
professionals and we listen to that
feedback that
feedback um really helped shape our
Draft rules Christine Downing who was
mentioned was tasked with
reviewing the Draft rules and giving us
feedback which we took a lot of
Christine's recommendations are
incorporated into these rules we gave
her over an hour if recollection servs
on the time maybe approximately an hour
at a public uh meeting of the Board of
Education to go over in public her last
round of recommendations in addition to
the recommendations that she was making
through the channels that were set up
you know outside of the public meetings
we had three public hearings in April we
we had um hours and hours and hours of
public hearings um and we incorporated
that you will see that the Draft rules
that were the initial proposal in
February is vastly different than the
proposal than the final version that you
have here and that's because we took
massive amounts of input so it simply
isn't true that input wasn't solicited
that input wasn't taken and the input
wasn't incorporated into it um
we made tons of changes based on the
input we received from the general
public from legislators and from
professional
Educators and that process is uh laid
out on a on the department of Ed website
as
well that's the
um my response I think Julie has some
response in some of the technical uh
allegations of not providing information
um Julie Shay Department of Education
um as far as the legislative oversight
committee um we actually appeared twice
in front of them um the first time was
in June um the second time was later
and I have an email from August 19th
where representative cordelli asked me
for a copy of the final proposal which I
provided to him I was not asked to
provide any copy to the committee um
other than that and in the meeting I did
say that the copy they were looking at
was incorrect but I was not the one that
provided it and then I told them where
they could find that copy because I had
sent it I didn't realize that he hadn't
shared it with the rest of the committee
we weren't trying to give somebody an
incorrect
copy
um and that's what I have to say about
that and as far as the legislative
oversight committee um they are a
committee that makes recommendations and
they did make a recommendation to us we
were invited to speak several times um
at one point as um attorney Brown
mentioned earlier she just had surgery
so she was unavailable to come to the
meeting the commissioner was also
unavailable and I as the administrative
rules coordinator manage the
administrative process of the rules and
it would not be um beneficial to anybody
if I showed up to that meeting alone to
answer policy questions because I am not
equipped to answer questions about
policy on rules I'm happy to answer
questions about the process and what we
did for that but I don't think it would
have been appropriate for me to answer
questions about academic standards or
through probably only a couple of minor
things to that I want to point out um
for the minimum standards because these
were important rules because this was a
long process we made a determination as
the department to create a separate web
page for the minimum standards um it has
been updated every single time there's
been an action so on that page you'll
find the initial proposal you'll find 's
comments to the front half and the back
half you'll find the final proposal
stage um there there it includes also um
all of the information regarding the
educator cohorts the different meetings
that were had the listening sessions all
of the list of the the many listening
sessions this is the most transparent
process that I I have been involved in
in my two and a half years at the
department for rules we have done
everything we can do to make sure that
folks are on the right page and when I
say that I mean having the right copy um
having the most current version of the
rules that should be part of the
discussion um speaking toward um the
legislative over site committee I think
I two comments I did in fact from my um
bed listen to that meeting and and Julie
does properly summarize that the
questions that were being asked at that
meeting were very policy oriented they
were not procedure oriented they also um
are policy questions that are well
within the right of the legislature to
revise make changes to outside of the
scope of this gel car um we have Tak
um we've had the first round of uh
comments that we received um from the os
office to the initial proposal had
substantial uh comments changes
recommended revisions those were taken
very seriously by the state board by the
department many hours were spent with
the people at this table reviewing the
comments that we received from Os Os is
reviewing those rules for the sole
purpose of advising this committee to
make sure that we follow the process
that the rules are bound in statute and
we are not overstepping our legislative
Authority we worked very diligently we
are but this team worked very diligently
together we also met multiple times with
OS that process resulted in what you'll
see as the very minimal comments that
you now see from OSS who are Adis ing
you with respect to whether we have
followed our rule process you will see
basically typographical changes is the
only thing that you'll see it indicates
that your staff believe that we have
followed the process at this point um
and that we have made the changes that
make this in compliance with the statute
and the process that we are required to
follow and that this committee is
required to follow and so I think most
importantly look to OS to just the types
of changes and the types of concerns
that they currently have with this draft
and they are minimal concerns which we
have addressed the um one so second I
want to speak to legislative oversight
legislative oversight voted in favor of
the rules on the condition that we make
a a change to the definition of educator
after reviewing that we did make that
change in the conditional approval it is
so noted that was submitted to OS that
is in the draft that OS reviewed prior
to the time we came here um with respect
to public comment the rule the law that
was in effect at the time that the
public comment was received and is still
in effect we were required to provide a
report indicating how we had received
taken in and responded to the public
comment in the draft that you were
reviewing we complied with um with the
current law in so doing um I think this
process has been Thor
complete and I think that I would look
if I were on this committee to the
comments of OSS and use that as your
guide with respect to whether these
should be approved today um to the
extent that the legislative oversight
committee made re uh recommendations
that they believe were not followed that
they are a legislative body and we are
leading into a legislative session and
those changes could be
legislatively addressed but these rules
comply with current law and I think your
Council and your representatives from
OLS will advise you that that is in case
the fact that we have done everything
within the um the the role um
importantly I think
um the comment from uh regarding whether
or not um we have that that these are uh
contrary to um the public public
interest that's a very that's a term of
art when it comes to this committee and
that is really making sure that the
public has had an opportunity to be
heard and we this state board has given
the public multiple opportunities to be
heard three public hearings on these
rules and this committee has given the
public opportunities to be heard and
there changes have been made to the
rules based upon that comment so there's
no concern that this has not been a full
vetted process and the public comment
has not been considered and heard thank
you yes and there is in fact a report on
comments it's on page six of the F of
the meeting packet with the revised Rule
and it starts
by um they had 223 public
comments during the initial period and
116 of them expressed General opposition
to wholesale changes but did not
identify specific areas of concern and
then there are some comments that were
specific including one from Miss wilky
and to to make change to incorporate the
academic standards that have been
approved to attach those by
reference
deleted uh change the word curriculum to
program and may may include was deleted
throughout the
proposal and and as I said the class
size limitation was recopied from the
pre the currently approved rules so
there's I can't
say that
the board of education did not follow
the process and listen to the public
they may not have Incorporated all the
comments particularly those that are
policy
issues and but they have in
fact uh received the comments and acted
on many of them any any other comments
or questions representative Vera thank
you I do have um a
comment referring to House Bill 1622
starting date on December 9th it was
used in the previous rules as a reason
to step back
so I don't know how we would not apply
it to this rule as well even though it's
not in fact the intent is there number
two one of the things about public
hearings is that they are to be
transparent and when someone from the
chair has a meeting with and I'm not
looking at either one of you as that
when when the chair of a of a when the
commissioner of a department meets with
a PRI with a member of the commission or
a committee and then report reports back
to the committee and is not there to
have a public discussion at a public
hearing that is an issue of
transparency number three House Bill
1671 and
1691 were attempts in the last term to
address some of the changes that are
made in these rules and those bills did
not pass they failed in the house
therefore that shows legislative intent
that the that the changes in these
documents are against legislative intent
which is another component of our
reasons to
object number three there was no
discussion um this year in in um the
last year of this of this uh term House
Bill 1107 passed the house and was
signed by the governor and it is meant
to update the Frameworks so why would we
use use Frameworks that are decades old
to when they are meant to be updated and
have been asked to be updated by the
legislature
another legislative intent
Point um would you please answer the
question about the Frameworks because
that seems worrisome well I would be
happy to do that uh we incorporated I I
assume you're talking about the um State
academic standards right okay um
anybody here who's not familiar with the
process of updating the State academic
standards might not understand that it
takes uh years for each one when I first
got on the board we did some of those
and it's a approximately two-year
process to update academic standards I
have right here the academic standards
that have not been
updated this would take each one of
these would take years to do
um it is not realistic or advisable to
hold the update of the minimum standards
until we take probably 12 to 16 years to
update all these academic standards they
are Incorporated by
reference because these are the
standards we have most of these are
common core standards so I know we've
had lots of arguments um about those
over the years um updates to those would
change change the common core
standards we are keeping them in place
when they come up for their proper
renewal the intent is to take them up
and renew them but it takes a lot of
work um we're a small board and we take
these uh standards updates very
seriously and we want to give them our
complete attention it's simply not
realistic or practical to hold up the
306s until every academic standard can
be updated
yes and I would mention that the 306
rules could be very quickly amended if
you needed to update the version of the
academic standards and that and that
that M Madam chairman is why we
incorporated it by rule right so the 306
is previously would have to be amended
themselves if they had these written
into them because we incorporated them
by rule we can update these academic
standards without going back and
reopening the 306 is much more efficient
and um May I assume that the board of
education is planning to actually update
those on a plan schedule and what which
academic standard are you currently in
the middle of uh we are not in the well
we we had social studies um before covid
we were working on that and we made a
lot of progress and it got disrupted by
the covid process that would be the one
that we would probably take up first um
but there's a lot of them that that uh
really do require attention and revision
and we intend to get to those do you
have a a schedule or a plan I hope I I
have a spreadsheet of all of the
standards when they are adopted when
they're due to be reviewed and we're
starting to work on what that will look
like um I did I do also want to point
out in the front half we did adopt a new
rule that shows um a process by which
the state board will um not only take up
academic standards but review them on a
10-year period prior to that and the
legislative update there was no timeline
for updating academic standards like
there is for rules and so now that we've
set that in place we now have a
mechanism where we will have a schedule
to update these standards and make sure
that they're reviewed and again as as
chairman Klein stated um it it doesn't
make sense to um not update the rules
with these standards because they
haven't been updated the process now
that they're in rule is to now look at
them and update them and use the um
expedited process to change the
Incorporated references as necessary
once we update them and that will be a
much quicker and administratively
efficient process thank you represent
and that role is Ed
30626 it is on page 33 of the amended
conditional approval request thank you
and and just to the point we also
received a lot of public input regarding
the academic standards and the fact that
there was no review cycle which is one
of the reasons
why I took the lead in drafting this
Rule and and it be so we would have a a
process established in our rules because
it wasn't established by Statute and it
wasn't previously established by rule so
yes it's the last page that you should
look at page 33 um represent do you have
a quick
question I do Madam
chair um I'm sorry that you have so much
paper work but I can assure you we do
too and um that's part of the work part
of the job and the reason why we're
here and um my comment is why would we
adopt rules that are as old as 2001 and
in the case of social studies 2005 and
why did you not update these Frameworks
if they were so meaningful to the
department and or to the school
districts no speeches please they have
already stated they are develop they are
instituting a planned R update of all of
their standards and I believe social
one representative Leon um thank you
madam chair I had actually been somewhat
troubled by The Common Core inclusion
but as I looked at it I appreciate the
process that you have for updating the
academic standards um I wanted to speak
to representative gr's um comment about
the previous rule referencing House Bill
1622 it did not um there are the
existing um standards for considering
public comment pursuant to RSA 44
54111 there are already standards there
and I was referencing those and not
specifically House Bill 1622 quite
frankly it would have been very
convenient to speak to the fact that
there's been so much public comment and
we want to understand how it's been
included but when you look at it and you
look at the volume of work both in this
and in the landfill one if we were to do
that and have them go back go back
through their work go and dissect what
they did what they included when and
where that process would probably add a
year to both of the rules and I know
that people who don't like the rules
would be happy about that but it also
would just grind things to a halt we
already dealt with that with covid with
everything else that came up and took
people's Focus off of the normal process
of government and dealt with the new
crises that we had trying to take a law
that we have and then go retrospectively
to apply it to our process wouldn't be
appropriate
as convenient as peronet might find it
and quite frankly it would have been
nice to have that on the landfill but we
can't do that we can't change the
conditions prior to the effective date
of a law and so we move forward and
it'll be great to have this transparency
but we can't go back and change the past
on this so we move forward and I I
believe that the process um has been
pretty extensive I've worked with I've
worked with the education and I've
worked with the people in that committee
and I know there's always Viewpoint
differences but I I I believe that I
believe in the process actually the
landfill rules do have a fairly
extensive report on how they address
public
comments and it is full of technical
details that I can't evaluate if it
shows they Incorporated them or not but
they're there representative fellows you
had a question um yes within RSA n21
there's a description of the Department
of Education in the bureaus the the
divisions and the bureaus and one of
those bureaus has a responsibility to
maintain and update the um standards the
minimum standards so I really don't
understand why since there's staff
available that there has no no rule has
been no work has been done on updating
these Frameworks Senator Whitley's right
here can you explain that Whitley's
right here Le not sitting in for anybody
I I I without speaking directly to that
state law um the Board of Education that
takes up the uh state standards and
we're charged with um reviewing them
adopting them and um again there there's
a process to do this but um and and just
to representative gr's point I'm not
complaining about the paperwork of the
work burden I love this work so you
won't hear I'm not that's not a
complaint to point out that this is a
lot of work um we are obligated to
update the rules every 10 years we are
it's a conveyor belt right so every
state board meeting we have new rules
that have expired or going to expire
that we have to update and that's a
that's a lot of work and the 306s were a
lot of work um the minimum standards or
the um academic standards aren't on that
same conveyor belt
so our workload is such that um we do
look for opportunities to take up
they our our focus is on doing Our
obligation to update the rules so I mean
that is kind of how it works on the
state board with a seven member board
with no staff and just to point out I me
the department has been amazing but the
Board of Education itself has no
staff um and we're part-time volunteers
so these things get taken up
um we think an appropriate rate but I do
I I just want to maybe point out that I
think I failed to understand the
argument
that we can't change the 306s and we
should keep the 306s the way they are in
current form
because the 306s are responsible for our
high academic achievement in New
standards have to be changed and it's
unacceptable that we don't change those
compatible thank you and I would
uh like to mention your staff has
apparently decided that you will be
reviewing the uh academic standards on a
schedule which which is good and I
support that I was glad to see that in
the rule because that you know I I think
that's necessary that's
probably to a large degree more
important than your rules yes and in
many cases that's more important okay
thank you I have a follow-up question
please um brief one please yes it is
indeed brief so um it is my
understanding and that the the board the
State Board of Education by
Statute is supposed to be compos is
composed of people who do not have
professional education
experience and that the department of
educa that is why one reason that the
Department of Education and the staff
that it employs who is charged with
maintaining and and revising rules are
professional
Educators would you like to respond to
that any change to that is obviously a
matter of policy and not of the rule I'm
referring to statute those are statutory
requirements that the board cannot be
professional Educators but the
Department of Education has staff who
are and can develop rules thank you
develop Frameworks I'm talking about
sorry Senator Whitley you had a question
I just didn't know if they wanted to
respond it's
okay no Madam chair thank you I you know
I just wanted to address an issue and
ask a further question there was a
representation made by the chair about
that there was quote disinformation
about class size ratio and I think
that's a very unfair characterization no
it's you have many qualified Educators
who have provided hours and hours folks
that are in the field administrators
that are in the field sharing
information about how there is clear
confusion in the language here over how
many certified teachers must be in a
class with students um and so you know I
want to uh ask you to respond to that
why it's disinformation when there's
clear confusion excuse me senator
the
disinformation is that people were
responding to the
preliminary rule after it had been
changed by the Board of Education to be
exactly the same as the current rule
which does have specific educ specific
limits well we'll let him respond
because my understanding was the
disinformation was over the class ratio
and my second point to that if you can
respond to is sort of this is a very
substantive BAS Bas on what the
qualified Educators administrators are
saying about this confusion about how it
is making a substantive change about you
know that's really not directed by the
legislature sort of what is the
authority to to go beyond that
Authority we have not gone beyond any
Authority that's incorrect um we the
disinformation is as chairman Maguire
said uh we months ago and I don't
remember the exact timeline here
somebody could look it up if they wanted
to uh Incorporated
the um current class size ratios into
the new rules we made a point of stating
that fact at board meeting we put the
rules out there and after that fact
people continue to falsely claim that
there's no class size ratio in there
that's the
disinformation yes I got an email just
yesterday that said that we need to have
class siiz ratios in these room rules
follow up please yes right but the
information that is being provided is
not disinformation because you're
looking at the to what people are doing
is looking at the totality of the rules
in addition to the definition of an
educator I'm sorry the senator in 306 14
the class size ratios are are in the
rule so it's disinformation to say that
they're not there so in the initial
proposal the class sizes were removed
there were extensive comments on that in
in the next proposed draft the class
siiz section was was added back into the
rules specifically based on that comment
that's why it removed my comment on the
state educator ratios because they put
it back in it is in
30614 and it says clearly the school
board shall establish student student
educator ratios an educator has been
changed to the definition in 21 in 8D
which says teacher and certified par
professional um the ratios that promote
student learning for each learning
opportunity and learning level based
upon school safety policies content
instructional method the characteristics
of Learners and the following
kindergarten grade through two 25
students or fewer per educator grades 3
through 5 30 students fewer per educator
and middle school and high school 30
students or feral per educator it also
has um
aspirations that they try to have lower
ratios but they have set a
up so what I think the the confusion is
uh you have to read these rules together
and so the concern is the definition of
educator just as you're describing so
the concern is there is little
clarification about how many certified
teachers are in in the classroom and
that is the concern when you're reading
the ratio with the definition of
educator there is confusion about how
many certified teachers are required the
term educator is including certified par
PA of professional it is not you you do
have to read the rules as a whole and I
would like to point out
30612 says You must have an educator
with their content area leading a class
a certified paraprofessional cannot
teach a class they have to be certified
in their
area so that is when you read those
together each classroom for each
learning opportunity so again each
learning opportunity has to have these
ratios a teacher who is credentialed in
their content area so in a social
studies class A teacher who is certified
in social studies must be teaching that
class
thank you Senator Chandler thank you I
have just a very quick question that
might perhaps explain maybe not um the
some of the confusion and um I'm just
wondering if the conditional approval
request for the 306 is is currently on
the department of education's website
yes it is thank you yes but I will I
will say that from the the comments from
the public many people have not fully
analyzed the latest version and that is
something that is very common in the in
in the legislative process as well as
process representative uh fellows thank
you madam chair so you just made the
remark that this the ratio is based on
teachers who are credential in the
particular class area but this rule does
not say teacher it says educator and you
have also just told us recently that
educator
means um what certified teacher or
teacher or certified par educ teacher or
certified par
professional that particular um RSA that
you're referencing was was written only
a year ago and adopted a year ago and
the purpose of that particular RSA is to
describe a grant program to encourage
teachers and paraprofessionals to be um
part uh to be recruited and
educated so that they can increase the
number of uh teachers and Prof par
professionals available to our schools
because we know there are are short ages
of that how that that definition in that
statute applies only to that statute and
there is nothing else in all the rest of
the statutes that can support your um
definition that in a classroom you
should be using teachers and
paraprofessionals as if they are
Educators so the statute the statute in
8D is used by the department because
they are bound by 541a to use the
statutary definition of educator and it
is the only definition of educator in
the entire statute set so they use the
definition that they could use and like
like uh Julie Shay said if you read the
rules together it does not mean that a a
certified par professional would be
considered in the educator
um student ratio you have to read the
the the rules together you can't pull
out this one rule and say the definition
is not correct the definition is teacher
or par professional when you're using
the word educator in the ratios it means
teacher if they mean ex representative
fellows you've made your point please
don't
argue representative hacken Phillips
thank you madam chair um I I am
concerned with this definitional change
change and um I believe um there are
the calculations for per pupil costs
this calculation was not developed based
on class size ratios and so I think it
is unknown what type of fiscal impact
the shift to class siiz ratios may have
on our funding obligations
specifically
um when you shift uh it creates an
opportunity specifically for
downshifting of State funding
obligations to localities if local
districts are determining to offer more
than the minimum framework requirements
in a way that was not previously
happening so uh in addition when you
look at that committee's final report
State funding obligations are determined
by student teacher class maximums in
accordance with Essa standards and when
you switch from the class siiz maximum
to class siiz ratios um and when that
isn't enacted it will disrupt current
funding obligations because of the way
that that is calculated and I believe
that the Department of Education will
need to evaluate which districts are out
of compliance and to calculate the
different funding obligations when these
rules are put into effect I think both
will create additional administrative
costs on a local level and a Statewide
level and possibly change our funding
obligations but I'll note that there
have been there have been no fiscal
notes for either these local or
Statewide Department costs included in
the proposal for these rules I think um
the purpose of the state is to Supply
and adequate
education and you know this will have a
significant impact economic impact
locally and Statewide and the public has
a right to know whether it's a positive
or A negative local or Statewide impact
and none of this has been fully vetted
and I think this is another basis for an
objection to these rules um there is the
possibility and opportunity for an
economic impact here that has not been
fully Ved and I do believe that we need
to take more time to look into that um
the for this proposal Mr K you were you
were going to respond to that yeah um
again as was just stated for um quite a
while now the class size ratios are in
these rules they were not removed there
is no change to the class siiz ratios
one of the responses we got when we
floated the idea of going to ratios
instead of hard caps was exactly that
point you had made about calcul ating um
funding so in response to the feedback
again we incorporated the class- siiz
Caps into these proposed rules they're
in there in
30614 in
30612 it makes clear that you cannot
lead a class unless you're certified in
that subject matter so par professionals
under these rules may not lead teach
classes so those are myths those are uh
misunderstandings they're not true class
siiz caps are in and only certified
licensed teachers can lead teach
classes thank you also the fiscal impact
statements were done by the Legislative
budget assistant and they both proposals
have fiscal impact statements I do not
know the scope of how far they go
through what the they're they're doing a
fiscal impact statement on the the rule
text they don't go further than that
they have never been included in any of
our packets so this is new information
to the legislature the fiscal impact
statements are in all of the
packets representative Leon um thank you
madam chair the current rules state
kindergarten grade 2 25 students or
fewer per
educator it wasn't previously defined
ased I don't know if it was defined as
educator this is not a change in
language at all objecting to language
that is currently in statutes I don't
think makes
sense and that is no change from the
previous
rule okay anyone
move
okay Senator ward has moved to approve
second by representative
Leon any further comments questions
yes um I I think we need to take some
time to lay out why um you know I will
not be voting for the approval I think
there's multiple multiple basis uh for
objections and I will defer to some
objections I think we've heard them
representative hacken Phillips thank you
madam
chair so um I'd like to take a moment to
focus on the first half of the rules and
the public comment according to OS and
our leg ative admin administrative rules
office it's unusual for any rule to
change um and attract public comment
submissions toing more than a dozen
responses it's highly unusual for a rule
change to attract more than 200
responses and in this case more than
half of the 223 public comment
submissions were characterized to be in
general opposition to the changes that
the Department of Education initially
proposed so rather than reflecting upon
more than 50% return in the these
negative responses to the proposed
changes and determining the merits of
those highly unusual submission rates
for public
comment the state board and the
Department of Education effectively
overruled the 50% of the public comment
submissions without providing any
evidence on the merits as to why it
should dismiss the generalized
opposition and why it concluded the
proposal should continue so for instance
there was no discussion about why the
existing rules for our Public Schools um
our need of substantial change although
there was no legislative directive to do
so and such changes were contrary to the
unusually high rate of public opposition
the Deport the Department of Education
and the State Board did not provide full
analysis of the remaining 107 public
comment submissions to substantiate the
merits of moving forward with the
proposal and it is worth noting that jel
car has not been informed whether any of
the 107 remaining public comments were
generally positive in support of the
proposed changes and whether the
Department of Education investigated or
evaluated the merits of those claims
instead the final proposal responded to
nine issue areas of the education 306
rules that were publicly commented upon
citing approximately 25 parties
submissions but the final Pro proposal
does not address the any responses to
the approximately 82 remaining party
submissions and whether those comments
were evaluated or Incorporated based on
the merits so this summer uh when the
department Department commissioner
testified before the legislature that
some of the department conflict um
public comments had conflicted with
other public comments submissions but
the department never provided any detail
about those conflicting comments more
concerning however the Department's
failure to provide evidence for
evaluating the merits of those comments
or determining which side of the
conflicting comments were deemed correct
or valuable and whether those comments
or any proportion thereof were
Incorporated so instead the Department's
final propos proposal provided a link to
its website with all the public
testimony so that Jael car and thereby
the public could independently perform
the administrative work of evaluating
the remaining 82 comments and what is
most concerning is that gel car and the
public are left wondering how the
department determined the merits for
each and why it decided not to respond
so I read through the 593 pages of the
initial public comment period for the
front half of the rules and I found one
positive comment for the proposed
which can generally be um located on
page 329 so that's correct one of the
223 public comments can be generally
characterized in support of the changes
for the education 306 rules and
interestingly the single comments
General praise was centered around the
particular individual advancing compet
Competency Based learning in New
Hampshire but that point was Competency
Based learning and which type should be
Advanced um was later are than
contradicted by numerous other
submissions so again the department has
provided no explanation for how it
interpreted the particular conflict of
opinion and which side of the discussion
if at all has been Incorporated so the
pervasive theme Here is that dozens of
public comment
submissions in that final proposal is
watering down the existing minimum
standards for students including the
removal of class siiz maximum caps for
class ratios that does not include the
method for calculating those ratios or
the reference Chang from courses to
learning opportunities which has been
alleged to further exacerbate the
inequalities and inequities across the
state's Public Schools the department
does not address this concern or present
evidence that the changes would actually
strengthen our standards thus
overwriting the vast majority of these
public comments so you know you can look
to page 47 the demarks from Meredith
noted that there's been no research
based evidence shared by the department
to justify its proposed changes to these
existing rules which they believe is a
disregard for the Democratic process
there are additional multiple multiple
opportunities and um public comments
that were never responded to so the
members of Jael car have noticed the
dozens of emails addressed to us that
have come into our inbox this season
urging us to vote no on the final
proposed Ed 306 rules I've skinned my
legislative email inbox and I cannot
find a single email urging support for
this what is of greatest concern to jel
car is that in the absence of the
legislative directive to significantly
change the 306 rules the department
seems to be overriding the overwhelming
public disapproval of this proposal
without providing evid evidentiary
support for doing so and specifically
today I'm seeing that there are volumes
of stakeholder input um compiled by
Christine Downey and Educators across
the state um who are very concerned
about the legislative attent and the
authority of the agency to advance these
rules without incorporating in a
meaningful way their public input in
fact um I don't believe that they are
permitted to speak today in today's
testimony even though they're here
prepared to give testimony in the room
which I find is another piece of
evidence where the public comment is not
being fully meaningfully heard and taken
into account by our state I do believe
we can do better I do believe it's
against the public interest to move
forward uh without really having the
department substantiate its position in
a transparent way so there is evidence
to believe that you know despite the
reassurances we have heard over and over
again that the department has a greater
obligation to fully provide the evidence
and its evaluation of this public
comment period um I think we can do
better and I believe that the public
you
uh um just to be clear I did receive
public testimony for the this Jael car
meeting on these rules I evaluated that
the public testimony that I received and
all of them were referring to the
original draft of the rules they are not
relevant here which is why I did not
write write a summary of them the the
rules that the testimony that I have on
my desk now was given to me this morning
before the meeting it has not been
evaluated yet Madam chair can I just
respond to that wait just to be clear
too the your fiscal impact statement is
on page s
of the 202 2441 FP meeting packet and
the 202442 meeting packet on page four
there are two fiscal impacts for these
rules thank you may I just briefly
respond I do think that this is a due
notice argument we we are concerned that
members of the general public today do
not understand which form of the rules
we are moving to approve I think there
is a concern about what notice has been
given and what the actual public
believes we are doing today my concern
is that the first public
hearings that were held as we've heard
quite a long time ago more than a year
in some cases there has not been a
meaningful opportunity for additional
public input with a public hearing after
these rules have been changed so we have
multiple iterations of a new form of
this set of 306 rules without a single
moment in time where the public has been
able to weigh in with real-time feedback
to those changes to have that realtime
feedback incorporated into the new set
of rules so I am I am pumping the brakes
here I do believe there is a public
interest concern worth evaluating if I
may respond to that um first of all I do
want to point out that these rules were
set to expire in March of 2024 so if we
did not move forward with changes we
would have no rules and so that is why
we're moving forward um additionally we
are not required by 541a to offer any
additional public hearings beyond the
ones we offered not to say that we
wouldn't however
the monthly state board meetings offer
public comment at the beginning of every
single meeting now if it's not you know
earmarked as minimum standards public
comment people can still come and speak
and they have um and people have had
ample opportunity um to make their
feelings known on the proposal
additionally we did release and post on
our website which was not required of us
all of the public comment so that
everybody could see it um a lot of the
public comment was General
opposition which is which you can
understand but there's not anything that
we can do to make changes based on that
we have to move the rules
forward the rules are set we set to
expire they are under an extension from
a14a meaning after Jael car final action
they will be valid for 30 days if the
department does not adopt um so several
of these rule sections are set to expire
when this process is over thank you
Senator Whitley thank you madam chair I
just want to be clear about um the basis
for an objection which is why I you
believe strongly that we should all vote
against the motion the motion to approve
uh one that these rules are contrary to
legislative intent two these rules are
contrary to the public interest and
three based on the impact the economic
impact of these rules these are three
basis for for objection I've been on ja
car now four years I've never seen a
stronger case for an objection I've
never seen a stronger public outcry
asking us to object and so I just wanted
to make sure that was clearly on the
record thank
you anyone director moral um with your
permission I'd like to briefly Explain
how and why we have different versions
benefit okay
please um in February the department um
the board excuse me the board approved
its initial
proposal um I think that may have been
somewhat hurried that's my own opinion
because they were heading towards a uh
expiration date of the current rules um
there were significant changes in it for
example the educator p ratio was going
to be left up to the individual
districts um after the initial proposal
public comment was received Department
drafted its final proposal was based on
public comments their own concerns and
OSS comments um the final proposal was
approved by the board in August August
14th of this year they filed that final
Proposal with us
um I'm not sure if it was before the
conditional approval but on
819 yeah uh September 12th conditional
approval was approved by the board that
amended when the final proposal was sent
to us OLS the committee's attorneys
review that and make comments on that
the board then reviewed those and said
yes we can make some further changes
thus the conditional
approval last month the committee heard
testimony on this proposal and
subsequent to that the depart the board
also did an amended conditional approval
to make further changes and that's what
the committee is considering today the
amended conditional approval so it is
essentially the fourth draft of the
rules and all of these drafts have been
posted on the education website I have
followed them on the website our process
is not um we don't post every proposal
that is filed but we have have all of
our files are open record for anyone if
they ask me for any proposal or any
Proposal with my comments on it they
will get
it
okay Senator gr uh point of order um I'm
wondering whether or not we have a
motion in front of us but I'm wondering
whether a an objection would be a higher
priority uh that I've heard two one
Senator and one representative say that
you know they believe that they have
grounds for an objection if we can deal
with that then we can get on with the
rest of it um if that uh motion
fails uh does anyone in the staff know
what the priority of motions
is the first motion have has to be
removed okay it has to be removed the
easiest way to remove it is to vote on
it is that if that is
agreeable Senator Chanley I believe you
had a comment
yes and and and I acknowledge uh uh
Senator Gray's point that we are we are
discussing we are in the middle we have
a motion on the floor but just I I was
curious you know we've talked about this
version that version I asked you know is
the most is the
um the uh conditional
approval version on the department of
education's website the answer is yes I
was trying to part of the pro reason I
when you click on it it says page not
found now I may be doing something wrong
but that is what I am getting so I don't
know so my concern is you know at least
I just raised the issue that there you
know it isn't for necessarily for lack
of trying that people are not working
from the correct version I just want
thank for that
thank you madam chair so I I want to
acknowledge that uh a tremendous amount
of effort has gone into this on the part
of all the parties who are involved
closely it's not for lack of effort uh
but there this is very complex in term
procedurally and structurally and so
forth and so the fact that the public is
not completely on board or completely
informed is a simple fact they're not uh
that that's not for a lack of
trying I I think we've come a long way I
don't think we're there yet I don't
think these rules should be opposed
approved at this time and so I'm going
to be voting to object if we ever get
there and I'm going to be voting no on
the approval motion if we have to come
to that Mo vote first thank you thank
certainly
okay representative Lyn have you you
have a comment no no I thought ready
okay fine we will be doing this as a
roll
call Representative grota could we
clarify what is the motion the motion is
to accept the final proposal okay it's
the approv in one they approve the final
proposal and the amend
conditional approval request Madam chair
wouldn't we need to hear the second half
of of the 42 proposal before this is
only on
41 this vote this motion and this vote
is only on 41 fine this is the uh the
first the first to packet all right
Representative groa no representative
Lon yes representative Lynn yes
Senator gray yes Senator Chanley no
Senator see representative duet for
Senator
Ren Senator Ward yes Senator Whitley no
and it's 10:30 I think we should take a
10minute
break
e
we've had 15 minutes of our 10 minutes
minute
normal okay we are resuming
on Final
proposal
202442 minimum academic
standards Madam chair yes I just want to
um
ask uh fervently request that we provide
opportunity for people that yes I I I
was reminded that we need to provide
opportunity for public comment thank you
the previous set of rules we had public
comment last month and that's why I was
only going to have a procedural comment
from the
representatives and if anyone had new
information but this one is the first
time we've dealt with this package
therefore we will have public comment
thank you madam
chair
so so this is uh 202442 it includes Ed
36.2 7 through Ed 3062 39 it is the
minimum academic standards for public
schools um on October 29th the
legislative oversight committee for the
education Improvement and Assessment
program voted 4 to two to recommend
support for this proposal and there were
no recommendations for this half of the
rules I have no further substantive
comments thank you so there are no
comments we're going to open it to P to
public
testimony and I
will specifically ask that you not
duplicate previous
speakers
um Mrs
roers oh she stepped out
okay and I am not intending to give
everybody 15 minutes because that will
be
duplicative what did you say yes she is
here she is here oh thank you I you I
speak hello my name is Ashley de R roer
I'm a resident of Rochester New
Hampshire I'm a mother and my child goes
to schools I'm here today specifically
to speak one as a parent as a taxpayer
and as a concerned citizen I want to
emphasize first that the fact that I
wasn't able to speak for the first part
of these
rules speaks to a larger issue here that
public interest is not being
considered which is a factor in
objecting to these first first part of
these rules that went through there is
clear confusion and concern from
citizens and people in this state
regarding the changes of the 306 rules
however it moves forward
regardless as it relates to minimum
standards the legislative oversight
committee has not reviewed such
Frameworks that are being described as
being changed why is that where is the
public interest in this in this matter
are we informed about such Frameworks
what are
they they're not clear to us as a parent
I'm not being informed about such
Frameworks there's also the word program
what does that mean they talked earlier
about how the minimum standards there's
no schedule they don't even know what
they are there's a lot of words salad
around
that so I want to understand that and
it's not clear so there's now to be a
vote
on these minimum standards that we are
hearing there's no schedule to even to
even change them oh we haven't had the
time there's no
staff such excuses there's no there's
absolutely no excuse for that this is
their
job but yet all this time has been taken
to change these 306 rules this doesn't
make sense and I explained this to Madam
chair
in the fact that the fact that the
there's all this public outcry saying
that hey we don't like this and there's
not a lot of specifics around why we
don't like it well maybe because there
is inconsistencies and it's confusing
which again gives more reason to
object and if the legislative oversight
committee did not have the ability to
review minimum standards is it because
there aren't any minimum standards what
are the standards what are the
Frameworks are there any how could there
be any Frameworks or standards if
they're not present it's contradicting
and it's contradictory and it's
concerning how could we fund something
how could we pay for something how could
we send our children to schools for
something if we don't know what we're
to I'll pause for a second because I
want to read something that's very
I also want to emphasize and I said this
to a couple members in the
chairwoman I understand that the general
court website does have the updated
versions and the unconditional approval
as such but um as it was stated by I I
can't remember her name Julie who is up
here for um the commissioner of
Education Department of Education that
the their website had the updated rules
the page was not found when clicked on
that link and it was 5 days of that and
I had been looking at that so for any
parent any person in the public anyone
trying to see that and was being told or
maybe thought that it was there it says
the page isn't found which one could
lead somebody to
well this service this part of the
government is not functioning for me or
maybe it's in the process of being
updated again maybe it's under
construction maybe nothing's happening
with this where would that lead us
that's not one it's not transparent it
leads us to wonder what's going on in
the first place maybe it could have said
hey the page is not found please refer
website that didn't happen
transparent I'm looking for a quote
important it's by Thomas
so Thomas Jefferson recognized that
democracy only educated people can
accurately evaluate the governmental
them is the committee this Jael car
committee even
educated on what we are voting on
today I'm not even educated on it I
standards this is not in the interest of
know Jefferson wrote to a colleague
about public education in
1786 no other sure Foundation can be
devised for the president ation of
freedom and happiness preach my dear sir
a crusade against ignorance and
establish and improve the law for
educating the common people let our
countrymen know that the people alone
can protect against the evils of Kings
Nobles and Priests and that the tax
which will be paid for this purpose is
not more than the thousandth part of
what will be paid to the Kings and
Priests and no who rise up among us if
ignorance please object to this part of
the
rules thank
good morning my name is Marsha mcaffrey
I reside in the village of kukuk I
retired from State service to years ago
but for 23 years from 1999 until
2022 I was the state Arts consultant at
the Department of
Education I'm here to speak on behalf of
all the people from around the state Who
provided feedback and testimony
regarding the revision of 8306 standards
during public hearings particularly
those in support of systematic and
sequential art music and physical
education programs in our schools I'd
like to add that I had put in a request
to provide this testimony in the first
for the first packet uh so I am being
called now while this is part of the
second packet so I will uh modify my
statements many of my concerns were
addressed uh testimony from
representative M uh Miler particularly
around House Bill
1622 uh the timeline for that uh is to
go into a effect is December 9th that is
a mere 10 business days from today and
the first half uh which has already been
voted on my recommendation was to have
uh this deliberative body uh request
public uh a a public comment report um
on that half I do believe there is still
time because the second half is uh for
gel car is December 30th so I believe
that would fall into the timeline for
requesting a report of public comment I
think that uh what became very clear to
me in the first half for the packet of
the the first half of these standards is
that there is a great deal of confusion
I just went on my phone to look up the
final proposal which I
studied for many hours last night I
pulled it up on the department of Ed
website now I don't even know if that's
really the final proposal I don't know
anymore I am I am very confused and I am
very Adept at understanding this process
ed360 6 and that does apply to this
second half the back half uh the Arts
curricular framework um I was uh the
lead for that for the 2001 curricular
framework which is um referenced in the
final proposal of the Ed 306
standards that's a curricular framework
that uh
identifies proficiency standards by the
end of grade four by the end of grade 8
and by the end of grade
12 that is a document by which local
school districts are then to build a
sequential and systematic
curriculum and those are targets at end
of those grade levels my concern as I
ed360 they do not have to offer to all
students a sequential opportunity for
learning
in any of our content
areas through and if this is the input
system this current version also changes
language from will provide to the local
school board will ensure well how does
one measure an insurance how if it's our
input system why aren't we asking local
school boards to provide rather than
just ensure and words really do matter
and these are concerns I have looking at
it from someone with over 20 years of
experience going into schools and
reviewing for adequacy and reviewing
schools against minimum standards how
might we Pro are in
uh measure those
inputs so I do believe there are many
[Music]
um many strong aspects I have I also
know that the state has been on a
trajectory of Competency Based education
for 25 years and the standards as I read
the final proposal are a continuation of
that pathway for competency-based
education I still believe there is
confusion about what is Competency Based
education and I do believe that there is
no rollout plan that the department has
win and win these standards because
eventually they will pass there needs to
be better communication about the whole
concept of these standards what these
mean to schools and communities what
these opportunities are for students and
how this makes uh um is progress because
the standards as they were were pretty
darn good and so to make changes that
represent something more of a
reimagining of our standards I think
takes more effort from the Department of
Education and I would be very interested
in seeing the uh the sequence the
Cadence of Standards academic standards
revision um that would be very important
to include in a rollout plan and a
communication tool I thank you very much
for your time I appreciate the
opportunity to speak thank
and
I and I think it would be uh useful if
the Board of Education were to publish
their schedule of updates to those
Rumble thank you madam chair and uh
members of the committee like the
previous guests I was prepared to speak
about part one with new arguments about
the most recent regulations and was not
given the opportunity but I will respect
what's happened and just go right on to
part two part two also suffers from the
fact that it doesn't comply with New
Hampshire statutes New Hampshire
statutes require that schools shall
provide instruction and also that they
shall use an input-based accountability
system the proposed regulations do
neither of those two things so first of
all the current regulations and statutes
require that students that rather that
schools provide instruction that's the
how curriculum that's the what and
teachers that is the who for each
subject in this thing you'll see there's
13 subjects it's broken down into an a a
b and a c the a is the elementary the B
is the middle and the C is the high
school the proposed regulations remove
the requirement of a program that
provides instruction and replaces it
instead with learning opportunities
offered so what is the difference the
curriculum is the what the curriculum is
a list of topics ideas and materials it
has no action without instruction which
means the presence of Educators and who
is an educator under the regulations
under the current regulations that
educator must be a teacher that's in
30602 definition of educator because it
refers should write over to another
statute that is solely for teachers
under the proposed regulation an
educator can be a teacher or a par
professional so the first thing these
new regulations do is get rid of the
role of teachers the second thing is
that instruction is the how which is
done by Educators it's led by teachers
these regulations get rid of instruction
there is no requirement that you provide
instruction in the the proposed
regulations learning opportunities is
what they give you as their new idea for
the future of Education now I think
learning opportunities are great if
they're added onto instruction from
teachers but to replace instruction
would be a major error for our state
they are vaguely defined how many
learning opportunities must be provided
to every student we have no idea and how
many students will actually access these
ideas right now the regulations you have
give you a solid guarantee the proposal
regulations remove the role of the
teacher and they remove the role of
instruction now you might say what
statute is in
violation RSA
18924 the standard School statute says a
few things of relevance to us first is
that the schools must be taught by
teachers taught by teachers that's in
the statute who hold valid credentials
It also says a standard School shall
provide instruction in all subjects you
have to provide instruction the previous
witness just told you the importance of
the word provide that's different than
offering an opportunity you have to
provide
instruction sometimes this gets
confusing look at it this way if you're
taking a road trip across the country
you go to Google Maps you got the little
blue line that shows you where you're
going that's curriculum instruction is
what happens at each stop along the way
where the teachers teach students at
stop one at stop two at stop three all
the way through stop 180 that's the
difference between curriculum and
instruction also the previous speaker
mentioned inputs I would refer you to
RSA
193e
3-b it's the accountability for the
opportunity for an adequate education it
says first sentence using the
input-based accountability system a
school shall demonstrate that it
provides the opportunity for an adequate
education under RSA 193 e2a by meeting
the requirements of paragraphs 1 and two
of the section one is the inputs and
part two is the output syst outputs
means how do you assess what happened
what these regulations have done is put
everything on outputs it's entirely a
curriculum based on an evaluation of
competencies but there's no guarantee
that there's any actual instruction
taking place there's no guarantee of
inputs the inputs would be removed and
this could have a massive implication
maybe in the property Rich towns it
won't make a big difference because
those towns will continue to provide all
the inputs that are needed but in the
property poort towns when they find out
that they don't have to provide inputs
you are now endangering the education of
communities throughout this entire state
that would be a major major problem
because the future of our country
depends upon it also I would also ask
you to look at a couple of other
regulations there's there's 13 subjects
I mentioned there's an a a b and a c
let's just take one example just to
bring it bring it home mathematics let's
just take subo C High School mathematics
the current regulation has 13 things
that have to be provided in the program
there are opportunities planned activi
ities concrete experiences
interdisciplinary interactions sustained
projects interactive instruction and
curriculum what it's replaced with is a
requirement that you have a curriculum
based on competencies that's it then it
says to the school boards you can use
the common core standard for mathematics
and that's fine but that's just the road
map there's no provision no requirement
that anything actually be provided it
tells school boards if you don't like
Common Core you can write your own how
many school boards in the state are
going to write their own curriculum for
all three levels of schools for all 13
subjects and then it also refers you
into the other two sections to a couple
of other sections in the RS which
provide no details no instruction no how
to make a satisfactory curriculum so
what I want to put you back to is this
the current regulations are strong they
require Educators be teachers and just
look at 30602 educator means any
professional employee of any school
district who position require
certification by the state board
pursuant to RSA
18939 the term includes administrators
Specialists and teachers and if you look
up RSA 18939 the whole section is called
teachers how are they chosen School
Board s select teachers in the present
regulations in every school right now
you have to have teachers leading the
classrooms if you're going to have 25
children you got to have at least one
teacher if you're going to have 50 kids
in a classroom you would need two
teachers under the proposed regulations
you would not need two teachers because
a educator can be a teacher or a pair of
professional that affects not only the
discussion in part one it affects the
discussion in part two because in part
two you're implementing it the who is
the teacher without the teacher you
can't have guaranteed quality
instruction I want to be clear I'm not
against par professionals my wife is a
lifetime special ed teacher every night
at dinner we talk about what happened in
public school today in the par
professionals do an amazing job without
them the schools could not function but
it is wrong for the state to pass a law
that would say that a par professional
equals a teacher and that's what you're
doing here today if that's what you want
to do then legislature propose the bill
next semester next session and say we're
going to change what it means to be a
teacher or a par educator but to Ram it
through through a system of regulations
through the back door that's not the way
New Hampshire should do government I I
believe that deserves a full discussion
thank you
thank
Downey thank you madam chair for
allowing me to speak um at your seats
when you came in you had two packets
from me um the first packet is got the
date November 21st 202 before on it if
you could follow along in that packet
with me I'd be real appreciative and
that way I can keep my comments brief um
so that you can all get to lunch uh
excuse me this that packet is for the um
minimum School approval standards the
The Madam chair the packet that's dated
November 21 2024 and it says to Jael car
members yes yeah um that is my testimony
on the second half of the rules based on
educator
feedback and then you should have a
second packet from me that says
executive summary 2023 educator review
sessions so you should have two packets
from me if you don't I've got a couple
extras just let me know absolutely um
yes I do we do have somebody else bring
here um if I'm not mistaken it says this
is written testimony
regarding the minimum School approval
rules we have um it says um feedback
relates to the minimum School approval
right yes we have moved on to the
minimum academic standards right are
these rules relative to the minimum
academic standards yes correct yep in
that case your heading is wrong y thank
you
yep so um I built this packet uh based
on the four objections that exist in RSA
541 1
a13 um and so I'm just going to try to
Spotlight a few things for you you've
got them you can read it um I do want to
make a quick note though that the second
packet you have um is the full
synthesized version of the 17 I know
that there were 13 listening sessions I
ran 17 educator review sessions
throughout the state I do want to
clarify a point that was made by chair
kleene I was not tasked that word
implies that somehow I was asked to do
this I did was not asked to do this in
fact I was part of a working group that
involved um some key players through
State organizations aft Nea New
Hampshire New Hampshire school
administrators Association and members
of the national um Center for Competency
Based learning and I was part of that
work group from November of last year
2023 to to January of 2024 and through
about a series of three me meetings of
that group with the commissioner I
negotiated cuz originally when I
proposed this idea it was met with
resistance that we would hold educator
review sessions so I just want to
clarify that point for the public record
I was not tasked I actually negotiated
and volunteered to do this um so moving
on service in that case we appreciate
people who volunteer to do this kind of
dirty work yeah well I I believe it's
important to um protect the high quality
of our public schools here in New
Hampshire um so I wanted to do this ex
um directly around your process and your
four objectives and what I did in this
document was present for you some
questions and some considerations that
you can review and think about because
ultimately it is your job um in terms of
what you do with these rules moving it
forward the first one is beyond the
authority of the agency and one of the
things that I want to point out in the
second half of this document um is this
conversation of um pulling out program
language that exists in the current
rules and um linking them to State
academic standards um and so one of the
things I would would ask you to think
about is that and I I do want to
preference my testimony is actually
based on your gel C uh gel car packets
that I pulled exactly from your gelar
website for the November 21st meeting so
I go to Jael car now to get the most
up-to-dated version and so all my
feedback is related to what you have in
your packets um if you take the um and
and part of this does deal with the
first section so just bear with me for a
sec here one of the things that's coming
out in the second half of the rules is
this notion of taking out program uh
programming language and then using a
direct point to the State academic
standards and so if you actually here's
here's one cause that I think you need
to ask yourself is what do we mean by
State academic standards and I will get
to there's a definition in the RSA that
comes later but if you just take the
current first half of the document that
you just approved and you do a control
find in that document you'll find 21
hits on the phrase academic standards
and that's what's defined in the RSA but
here where it gets a little confusing
you will get hits where it's just the
term academic standard and it doesn't
clarify are we talking about state acade
mic standards or are we talking about
District academic standards because as
you just heard um through David's um
presentation before there is leeway for
districts to set their own standards
their own academic standards you then
will get um one more and this is an
interesting one because you just
approved this in the first half of the
role you will get a hit that clearly
says districts academic standards and
then in the new section that the
department of Ed added with 30620 6
you'll get the majority of the 13 other
hits when you just search for that
academic standards that are linked to
State academic standard but that number
two one where it says District academic
standards now opens up this conversation
to the question that I give you all to
think about which is does the State
Board of Education have the authority to
use the State academic standards to set
the criteria for substantive um adequate
education and what is stipulated in the
RSA and rules regarding the requirement
of of of schools to implement or follow
the State academic standards I I'm going
to just peruse through my packet here
for you very quickly but on pages two
and three I give you some more examples
that that get at this gray area about
who has the authority on these academic
standards and which academic standards
are we talking about General academic
standards District academic standards or
State academic standards um and one of
the current rules that you just approved
which is 3064 in policy development
number 18 that was in the first half you
just app approved actually says that
promoting students from one learning
level or grade or another based on
achievement of competencies in alignment
with the district's academic standards
so we have a gray area here about whose
academic standards are we pointing to
and is there that if we link these
content areas to academic standards what
consistency do we ensure because it's
not clear in the RSA what the role of
academic standards play if you'll follow
along with me and go to page three in my
packet what I do think that you start to
get clarity of in terms of the RSA is
that it's really clear and I would draw
your attention on page three to
paragraph five where it starts with RSA
193 E2 that it becomes very clear from
the RSA perspective that we're talking
about the minimum standards for public
school
approval setting the criteria for AC for
educational programs educational
programs it doesn't say set the criteria
for for academic standards it says for
educational program and then on that
same page three if you go up to the top
paragraph you have all the definitions
there laid out including the new
definition that you just approved in the
first half on program
so on page three you can see all those
definitions because that RSA is
specifically spelling out those
definitions there's you can't make an
assumption that one thing means the same
and I can use them like synonyms they're
defined very specifically and here's
what I also draw your attention to
that's come up recently in discussion
with the passage of House Bill
1107 and the implementation of the state
curriculum Frameworks if you look at the
definition of what the state curriculum
framework says currently in the RSA that
got approved is that it will say an
organized plan of study that serves as a
guide and reference to what New
Hampshire students should know and be
able to do in a learning area and
identifies the academic standards
aligned to the learning area Okay so the
question has been where exactly do the
State academic standards live because up
above State academic standards are
simply means what students should know
and be able to do here's where you get a
little um I think something you're going
to need to talk about is we also know in
the new RSA that um integrated
curriculum Frameworks into it that it
also says the curriculum Frameworks are
not meant to be a state
curriculum and that means schools don't
have to follow this so follow my I'm a
I'm a mathematics teacher by trade in my
former day so logic model is something I
live by but if you follow my logic here
that curriculum Frameworks include what
students know and be able to do and by
the very definition in the RSA academic
standards Define what students know and
be able to do then one could make the
connection our State academic standards
live in our curriculum Frameworks but
yet our curriculum Frameworks would not
be mandated to our
schools I I want that to set for a
minute okay so moving on um I I'm going
to point you to page five there's I've
given you some more pause to think about
what the RSA language says and what's
being proposed in the rules and that was
to helped you with that first objection
area of beond beyond the authority of
the agency but I have a list of
conclusions here that I'm just reading
through them that I draw as a lay person
a 30-year educator doing this business
and for about 50% of that 30 years I've
been a district level curriculum
director I lead curriculum instruction
assess and professional de development
in districts across New Hampshire like
my counterpart Marsha good to see you
marer I also was at the Department of
Education during that time with Marsha
as the mathematics
consultant um but my conclusions are
there and I think one of the couple of
things that I want to point out to you
in that conclusion is this inconsistency
about to play between program what is a
program academic standards and
curriculum Frameworks and we know in the
RSA the RSA clearly says that the
minimum standards for public school
approval set they Define an adequate
education for educational programs a
program an academic standard and a
curriculum framework are not the same
thing and I'm going to tell you that
from my experience of over 50% of my
career of being a curriculum
director here's the easiest way that I'm
going to try to do it academic standards
do one thing for us and that's simply
tell us what do we want students to know
and be able to do a program will answer
what we call Four essential questions
and they are what do we want students to
know and be able to do how are we going
to measure report and track uh sorry
check the progress of our students so
that we know they're making the progress
they need to be number three what do we
do for students that go above and beyond
our expectations how do we provide that
personaliz ation that you approved in
the first half and the fourth question
is what do we do for our students who
may be challenged or may be struggling
that's a program there's a difference
between using rules to outline a program
that is set to Define an adequate
education and then simply changing those
rules to academic standards you lose so
much more in the consistency and the
high quality uh public school education
that I believe the state wants
so you'll have my conclusions there on
page five and then I bring you to
objection number two category objection
number two category is based on the
contrary to the intent of the
legislature I think we've talked about
this a couple of times already but I'm
not going to belabor it but there are
some very pointed contradictions to
State legislation in the areas of
personal finance literacy and logic and
rhetoric and I would would really
encourage you to read them in both cases
the rsas are clear that these do not
need to be Standalone classes that now
serve as additional credits for
graduation the rsas are very clear about
making these integrated applicable um
sub uh topics across other areas as well
and and while in public um meetings I
have heard the department say well we're
not going to prevent anybody from that
that's great to say it in public but if
that's going to actually be the practice
then let's get that in the rules and
make it clear that yeah they could be
Standalone credits but they could be
integrated and applied and let's be
clear about that I think the other thing
that comes out of play and this is
really on the bottom of seven in the top
of page eight of my report is this
notion the rules are going to expire
there's been General consensus around
the rules you know in the 10-year review
cycle if you go to the actual these are
the effect dates that exist in the
current rules for the areas that we are
talking about you will see that there
are seven areas that do need immediate
attention I'm not going to disagree
agree with Julie at all on that um and I
think there are ways that we can get to
them pretty quickly but then the next
set of rules in here don't aren't due to
expire till
2026 so go back to the RSA and if the
RSA 19 3E tells us that the job of the
minimum School approval standards is to
maintain the high quality of our public
schools and it's in there it says that
the phrase high quality is used there
then let's use this time to make sure we
have that I'm going to continue on on
page nine you have my proposal that on
three different occasions I sent it in
March of 2023 I sent it in April of 2024
and then again in July of 2024 my
proposal of actually how to do working
review sessions with Educators and to
beef up the rules based on this timeline
right here so that you have that on
pages 7 to 11 that's objection number
two that you could deploy objection
number three is based on determined not
in the public interest we've heard a lot
about that today given that RSA 541
really doesn't give us much guidance
right now I agree um with the
representative who said that the current
house bill that goes into effect doesn't
go into effect till December so we don't
really have too much guidance we have
some guidance on what we Define as
public interest right but one would
think that when it comes to public
interest you'd want to have the feedback
of your public school Educators so what
you're looking here on the page I'm on
page 12 on page 12 what you're looking
at are the five options that I proposed
in my educator review sessions um I had
close to now 300 Educators if you put
all 17 of my sessions together I had a
break I did some in the fall of 2023 in
sept um August and September and then I
did another round in March of 2024 your
grass not in color but I did send every
member of this committee a digital copy
of this earlier this week so you have
the color version of it but so you have
the graph the
84.9% of Educators who participated in
these re review sessions picked option
number five you can't see the because
it's black and white and then the
15.1% picked option number four 0% of
the Educators I worked with picked
options one two or three in terms of
completely pulling rule language about
programs out of the minimum standards
for public school approval and hoping
they would land in State academic
standards nobody was in favor of that
okay um so here's what I do want to say
I know there was comment earlier today
about you know
um the the the the rules that are
contained in the content areas and um
how some of the content areas we don't
actually have State academic standards
for um and so I wanted to give you
samples so Pages 13 through in my report
and these are only samples um I have all
the materials from the Educators on all
the content areas but if you actually go
through pages
13 through 28 those are samples and what
I set up for you in this was um in for
example I'm going to just use 13 as my
um guide to help guide you through these
pages is I took the content area digital
literacy now this is an interesting one
because we don't have State academic
standards for digital literacy and what
I gave you is the educator feedback and
I have to tell you I had probably 20 to
25 folks throughout the state in my
sessions just focus on digital literacy
and they they rewrote the rules one of
the things I've heard come back to me is
that when I sent things to the
Department of Ed people quickly scanned
the rules and said well they didn't want
to make any changes that is not true and
I have evidence in my document to show
you that um so they rewrote these rules
on the brand new 2024 national istd
standards for citizenship in digital
literacy and so you will see on page
13 through I believe it's 15 to the
middle of 16 those were the rules those
Educators came up with in fact I will
point out to you on page 14 numbers one
going to 15 to number seven are the
components of those National IST
standards they didn't copy them word for
word they synthesized them so they would
make sense and these are Educators so if
they're going to make sense to our
Educators that's important because then
they're going to be the ones that can
deliver that education to our students
and then on page 16 you will see what
ended up in the proposed rules
okay and you can see that all the way
through I would point out that PE which
is PE and health which are one of the
older sets of our current State academic
standards the teachers went through and
vamped those up to the to the also brand
new 2024 National shape
standards and you'll see those all the
way through uh page 19
um I will point out that I had a huge
group from the school Psychological
Services and our n our state
organizations and they put together
their rules that should be exist so
following every example of educator you
then have this is what is being proposed
in the um minimum standards for public
school approval um if you go to page 23
please those are the ELA rules and and
as we know those are common core driven
but I I wanted to leave the Integrity of
the review process in place so I didn't
clean these up I had told Cher uh
chairman Klein that I did not feel as a
single individual it was my authority on
any Authority authoritative level to go
through and then synthesize this
educator work and and put a best guess
forward that's why in July once again I
put forward the proposal of how to bring
smaller groups of educator together to
then come and synthesize a compromised
version of the rules that they would
recommend I left this in so they that
you can see they had cross outs they had
changes they had additions to it and
then you'll see if you go to page
25 these were the personal finance
literacy rules proposed and again this
one's interesting there are no State
academic standards for personal finance
literacy so there's a concern right out
of the gate remember included in the
first half that you just approved is an
additional half credit Standalone
personal finance literacy with with no
State academic standards to guide what
that is going to look like in our
schools I'm going to let that set for a
minute the Educators provided it you can
see the proposed rules here not a bad
match on this one I will I will give
full credit to that um but a nice step
in this process would have been hey
here's what all the different groups
came up with let's bring another working
group together let's meld it does this
make sense and then we've got consensus
on it right on page 20
s there is the logic and rhetoric again
this is concerning in what you just
approved you just approved
Standalone half Credit in logic and
rhetoric and there are no State academic
standards for this area now good news is
we had some groups tackle this it wasn't
easy because we had to do a lot of
research first around what's out there
what's the nation doing and there were
two versions and I didn't want to
Discount I didn't want to make an a a
authoritative decision on which version
was better or not so I gave you both
versions and then you can see what was
proposed in the rules to Define logic
and
rhetoric so conclusion here on your um
objection number three is determined to
be in the public best interest I think
there are enough questions here for you
to to consider that when you decide your
action that you're going to take the
last objection area is deemed by the
committee to have a substantial economic
imp impact um I just pulled out this one
area there were a few other areas but I
I wanted to keep this as manageable as I
could um and I did the the the quickest
comparison was the changes specifically
in the social studies area in the
credits for graduation and keep in mind
you just approve those changes in the
first half of the document so you have
approved now a change in how social
studies courses were 2.5 credits for
graduation are now five credits you've
doubled that that has to have an impact
on Staffing and scheduling at any high
school with no cost implications behind
it so I'm I'm here for questions um
thank you again for your time and for me
willing to present that
hello thank you madam chair for taking
my comments there my name is Shan par I
am the uh represent a representative
from Manchester's Board of school
committee and I do speak on behalf of
our school board today I am the chair of
the education legislation committee and
I have followed this process for almost
two years now
I have been uh I'm I should also say I
am an educator as well I'm a professor
at St anom college so I am quite aware
of the stakes of these changes to the
rules uh I'll try not to repeat things
but I think it is important to go on the
record that even just today there were
two falsehoods that were stated multiple
times that should be corrected one is
that the Department of Education website
does not have the most current version
of these rules on its website there that
is not possible for someone from the
public to access on the website so that
is false two uh there's been there were
many claims made about uh the class size
issue and that the wording in the
revised version is the same as the
wording in the current version and
that's also false the header of the new
section talks about student educator
ratios uh and the original stated class
size maximum and the class size is very
different from student educator ratios
our district has been very careful in
defining these things very specifically
in our own policies we feel it's very
important the research shows very
clearly that class size is much more
important than student educator ratios
that actually having a room with 20
students in it and one teacher is far
better than having a room with 40
students in it and two teachers or a
teacher in a parah that research is
substantial and clear and so we have
striven to continue that emphasis on
class size rather than student educator
ratios and if you look at the language
of the rules that you just approved it
is substantially different from the
current language and I think it's really
important that that go on the record
because that is something that uh was
discussed several times and several
that with regard to the second half of
the rules we would Echo
the comments from David Trumble that
these subject area requirements have
indeed been watered down Marsha mcaffrey
also pointed out many Salient points
about the Arts and uh how these
Frameworks are not mandated but
suggested Frameworks for schools to
follow and I think it's important that
we understand that that means that
districts can make choices to opt out of
offerings many of these things to opt
out of programming a real systematic
framework or systematic program of study
for our students in public
schools I would also point out that uh
our board has been particularly active
and we have been quite grateful we've
been uh lucky enough to have a visit
from commissioner edbl himself he came
to one of our Schoolboard meetings we
have held our own forums where Fred
veronte came and and spoke with us there
we've been very active in asking
questions involving the public as much
as we could we have given our feedback
several times to the State Board of
Education both in person and in writing
all of our letters have been unanimously
approved by our board we have a robust
strong board with lots of different
opinions uh I think I can say safely
that it's a bipartisan board and for all
of us to unanimously approve these
letters of concern about the rules
changes speaks very strongly to uh a
coming together of understanding the
stakes of these minimum standards and
the changes that are being made uh as
for making sure that we're talking about
the current versions there I can State
very specifically that several of our
concerns remain in addition to the
class- siiz maximum concern we also have
been very concerned about the vague
language changes especially the learning
opportunities the phrase learning
opportunities and the phrase learning
levels and we feel very strongly that
these changes are too vaguely defined
and uh water down the the minimum
standards for Education here we have
argued from the beginning from March of
2023 that it's been important for for
direct instruction to be fundamental to
minimum education standards and that
ideas of learning opportunities and
learning levels do not cover that
requirement of
instruction uh I would say two things
with regard to your committee jel car I
know that you have very specific rules
about when you can object there and I
think from our perspective as a board
public interest and fiscal impact are
the two concerns that we still have that
your your committee has the power to
raise objections to public interest has
not been addressed uh the the feedback
has been ignored we have we have called
attention to this many times over the
last two years we feel that many
Educators stakeholders and our entire
school school district has been
disregarded uh with regard to our
concerns we have uh we have been very
consistent in our
feedback in a way this erodes trust
right I mean public interest is not just
well we have concerns you're not
listening to them public interest is
also we need to trust that the State
Department of Education cares about the
feedback of Educators and school
districts we need to trust that when
they say something is available to the
public that it's available to the public
we need to trust that when they say
learning opportunities are the same as
direct instruction well we need
definitions that really show that and
prove that right so trust has really
been eroded in this case and there's a
reason why there are so many of us who
are upset that we couldn't speak before
the first part part of this hearing
there are so many of us that are
objecting the work that Christine
Downing has done to involve hundreds of
Educators on her own not at the behest
of the Department of Education that
shouldn't be happening that shouldn't be
necessary the Department of Education
should be doing that work they should be
adhering to that sense of reach Outreach
and trying to find ways to bring
Educators to the table so that these
rules really do reflect the best
interests of our students here in New
Hampshire finally
fiscal impact this was touched upon by
Christine Downing and others I think
that what has been maybe a little bit
less mentioned is that the vagueness in
terms of District versus State academic
standards that uh the definition of
adequacy funding is very much linked to
these minimum standards and what is
required there so if class size is
changed because it's not a maximum but a
student teacher ratio if academic
standards are
inconsistently uh referred to Via
District or State versus District or
state standards uh and if we have a
sense that these subject area program
requirements are now just Frameworks
that may be applicable then that is
affecting what the minimum the minimum
standards do affect what an adequate
education should be funded how it should
be funded there and so I think it's
really important that there be a a a a
deeper look at what the fiscal impact is
of these rule changes these are large
large scale changes they have a fiscal
impact they open the path for serious
cuts to public education funding and I
think it's really important that this
committee speaks out about this uh we're
just a hop skip and a jump from Arizona
who's done things like this Incorporated
Universal vouchers and now has like A1
billion deficit I mean this is this is
this is the direction with these rules
this is very fiscally irresponsible to
pass these rules without investigating
the the consequences the changes there
so I I feel very strongly about this our
board has discussed this many times and
I'm happy to answer
questions thank
you
fra yes so is your testimony in line
with the letter that we have from you it
is yes I think there was one of our
letters was included in your packet
there that was from September I believe
bar being steno here you know I am being
what you're being oh recorded yes not
recorded she is a court reporter thank
you representative Schmidt thank you
Gianna
you hello my name is GI jel I'm u a
parent of two in the O River Cooperative
school district and I'm also here as a
representative of the O River for uh
District School
Board I a lot of the things I was going
to speak about have already been touched
on so I don't necessarily want to repeat
them um the previous gentleman before me
actually said many of them but
considering what jel car is actually
limited to um the two things I really
want to talk about again is the public
interest and also fiscal impact first of
all there's a huge problem with actually
the clarity of this um I was actually
spending time during the first when we
were discussing the first half of these
rules about verifying that these
information was readily available on the
Department of Education website and it
simply isn't and hasn't been um the most
recent rules aren't there it's true I
can find them under jel car but that's
not under the Department of Education I
only see if it pops up in your guys'
packets so that's one thing there um
public interest has to be served by the
ability to read and understand it um
secondly I want to address something
that was in the first half of the rules
regarding the availabil of the
information regarding public hearing
sessions on this um I went to the first
public hearing session led by uh banti
um like two years ago that was actually
hosted at the orer River High School and
there was no information provided about
these regulations whatsoever they
weren't there he just talked a lot about
how awesome he was in competence based
education for two hours it was not an
informative
session so that did not address what was
happening here because
public interest was not served I
actually went at the end of that meeting
and actually asked him um what if you
guys considered the fiscal impact of the
changes in these regulations and he told
me
no so right from the GetGo these things
were not considering the fiscal impact
and as a school board
member the fiscal impact is incredibly
important um so I don't want to
reiterate some of things people were
saying but also again it's the the
adequacy funding and the link to it to
me is pivotally important no the class
size maximum and class size ratios are
not the same right now in our school
district we are having an issue with the
fact that our kindergarten population
exploded and we're actually having to
figure out how we're going to actually
add classrooms onto the current
elementary schools we have and a lot
that is absolutely linked to the fact
that we have limits on how many kids fit
in the classroom that's not just fire
code it's actually talking about how
well a kid is actually educated and so
we're having to figure out how we're
going to pay for that to make sure that
we fit these standards it's in our
policy and we are actually quite
understanding that there is a difference
between having an educator in the
classroom who is a teacher and an
educator who's a PA
professional so there's that there um
another concern we have that I'll
reiterate from other folks again is that
the learning opportunities learning
levels versus direct instruction is
pivotally important it's definitely a
watering down one of the things that I
actually have a concern about is that
that language makes it essentially that
a school district becomes a
credentialing Center rather than a
teaching Center and the difference of
that is is that with these learning
opportunities including the learning
everywhere program is that it makes it
so a school district is responsible for
an outside agency's teaching even though
the school district had nothing to do
with it they're providing something but
we're the ones who are supposed to be
evaluating it and assessing it and a lot
that language of like how you do
assessments and what's considered under
that has actually been removed under the
second half of the rules they it's not
there and so we're responsible for
something but actually have no ownership
and control over it um so again I I want
to point out learning opportunities
learning levels is not equivalent to
direct instruction and that go goes
again to the insur then provide uh
language that again is
problematic um one of the things that I
find concerning is that I think some
mentioned this earlier is that
competencies have not been very clearly
defined by anybody everybody's working
very hard on trying to figure out what
those mean and how you're going to teach
it and there's a huge amount that
actually our district right now is
working on professional development and
how to make it s our assessments
actually assess censes it is extremely
difficult work and when you make it so
the standards are removed in these rules
and it just becomes competencies you're
putting actually a tremendous burden
onto each individual district and each
individual teacher and administrator Etc
to try and figure out what it's going to
mean by removing guidance you've
actually put a tremendous burden
particularly
financially onto the districts as I said
where we actually just hired people we
hired a consultancy firm to try and
actually deal with this issue because
we're not getting the guidance from
somewhere every district is having to
reinvent the wheel here which means that
is an incredible fiscal impact that's
ongoing
um and I guess the last thing to go
through is again is that the the
question about who has the authority on
academic standards I I think is there
really needs to be looked at um Miss
Downing really addressed that
um that's basically a summary of that I
can answer any questions if I'm
you sir if you'd like to uh come up I
don't have your name name yet but I
speak Sean Sean yep Sean pesel um just
representing myself I am a resident of
New Hampshire and also an educator here
in New Hampshire too um just want to
call your attention to from my from what
I understand a procedural disconnect um
at an earlier meeting that the part one
of the 306s were um discussed in public
hearing and public comment was made um
there was a a request to hold off on
voting on that part um
in essence understanding because there
was known and made understood that part
one and part two should be heard and
listened together before making a vote
on part one that's where the disconnect
comes then here today you did not hear
testim new testimony on part one which
is totally fine your prerogative because
you've heard stuff before you heard some
procedural stuff from two
Representatives um but you did take a
vote on part one without hearing about
part two which is why um it was again to
reiterate why you held off on voting for
part one last meeting in order to vote
on part two today
now hearing the testimony for part two
um mostly from Christine Dowling she
highlighted for you very clearly the
connections multiple connections between
part one and part two with this stated I
ask for a vote of reconsideration that
you be be brought forward by prea by a
prevailing member of the prevailing side
meaning a person that voted to approve
part one and I ask that you reconsider
part one now hearing about part two and
vote on both parts one and two today
please thank you very
much my name is Mary Wilkey I'm a um
resident of conquered and I am a retired
school teacher public school teacher and
I have two uh concerns with the proposed
rules the first is that they exceed the
Department's regulatory Authority and
should be rejected um these proposed
changes uh to the rules represent
Monumental changes in the way public
education would be provided and go well
beyond the statutory authority of the
Department of Education uh the changes
reflect an entirely different vision of
public education than what we've had to
date a vision in which school districts
don't have to provide education they
have just have to ensure it and where
instruction may or may not be offered
and where class sizes may be determined
by the number of people in the room that
don't necessarily all um meet the
definition of teachers um you could even
interpret that section as allowing the
ratio to be to depend on the number of
qualified uh teachers and parent
Professionals in the whole Building
compared to the number of students in
the whole building um the proposed rules
consistently delete words like program
and then stuck and and instruction
indicating that schools will no longer
be required to provide systematic and
planned instruction vers via lessons
conducted by certified teachers as they
have been doing for
Generations the fact that the changes in
the proposed rules are so dramatic was
reflected has been reflected in the
outpouring of um of testimony against
them more than 200 people as you know
have submitted testimony critical of
these changes with many worried about
significant diminishment of the quality
of education and of our Public Schools
um it is true that after the public
testimony in April the board made some
changes in the proposed rules but if you
look very carefully at the wording of
those changes you'll see that in the end
the rules still would remove current
requirements that schools provide
systematic and planned instruction
offered by licensed teachers in classes
with reasonable size limits when RSA
193e was adopted to set forth the
content of an adequate education
legislators didn't have in mind a public
education system that would allow for a
smorgus board of optional experiences
that M or might not involve teachers
might or might not involve classrooms or
instruction in fact after setting out a
list of the learning areas in in uh
193e for instance language arts and math
Etc the legislature specifically
required that teachers use academic and
applied instruction to teach the
learning areas the rules deletion of
words like instruction and courses and
teaching and program um is a policy move
inconsistent with that language and with
the intent of the legislature in short
the drafters of these proposed rules are
imagining School in a very different way
from what currently exists from what is
expected by The taxpayers Who pay for
them and the parents who send their
children to them and from the
legislature itself certainly there's
room in the public discourse to imagine
various aspects or reimagine various
aspects of public public education and
I'm not arguing in favor of maintaining
the status quo for the end of time but
for an administrative agency to
Institute dramatic policy changes of
this kind through rulemaking is a
significant overreach of its Authority
and violates the constitutional
principle of separation of
powers I also am concerned that the
rules are not in the public interest and
others have mentioned this I won't
duplicate what they've said I have a
couple of different aspects I want to
mention um the New Hampshire Supreme
Court has written public education
differs from all other services of the
state no other governmental service
plays such a seminal role in developing
and and maintaining a citizen to be
capable of furthering the economic
political and social viability of the
state only in part two article 83 is it
declared a duty of the legislature to sh
cherish a service mandated by the state
constitution given their acknowledged
importance to our democracy our
communities and our students weakening
public schools by watering down the
minimum standards is just by simple
logic against public interest Common
Sense also suggests that if the
proposals were in the public interest
the public would want them and yet I
have yet to hear a single person today
last time and at the hearing in um in
April at the board ever urg the
department to adopt these rules moreover
um somebody else has already mentioned
the issue of equity and I um the idea
that the proposed rules make so many
aspects of Education vague or
non-mandatory that we can easily foresee
schools in some districts making choices
that wouldn't meet our current standards
simply because they're less expensive I
would just like to add to that that we
already have a school system that is
funded in a way that creates halves and
halves Nots depending on school on zip
code lowering the mandatory standards
which state what is expected at the very
least in every public school will make
these disparities worse which is of
course not in the public interest thank
you very much for hearing me thank you
for for your
testimony chairman Klein do you wish to
anything I'm GNA Department
else he may Chang his mind here shortly
the skill that I think I might have
tried to renew was a high school debate
trying to listen to everyone's comments
and try to make sure that I can address
everything I'm sure I'm not going to
address every point that was made um
holistically here
um I'm going to start with the same
premise that I started my last remarks
which is I'm going to take you all back
to why we're here
and who your council is and who's made
recommendations to you
and there have been go back through the
history the initial proposal was brought
forward there were lots of
changes recommendations for
changes comments from OS regarding that
initial proposal that was initially
passed by the state
board the State Board reviewed those
comments with that from o
comment made decision making made policy
decisions based upon that public comment
that was received we're not the State
Board is not legally compelled to adopt
all public comment considering the fact
some of it is contradictory it would
actually be impossible to adopt all
pieces of public comment and put forth a
amended proposal that's exactly what the
the process is OSS has reviewed that at
this point and has no objection and
virtually no comment again a couple
typos so that should be the first thing
you all look to at when you're making a
determination is what did your Council
say about these rules and whether they
should be
approved overwhelmingly your council's
telling you they should be approved
there were many many policy related
arguments that were brought up during
the hearing process in the last hour
plus um many of them did not relate to
the second half at all many of them
related back to the first half um if you
one there was and I think I have to
address this for the sake of my rules
administrator who has been accused of
lying and misrepresenting the facts and
and I think I was too that one of our
links on our website wasn't working um
so we learned today one of the links
wasn't working at no point in time it
was working when we put it up um our
requirement is to comply with 541a which
is to make sure that the public has
notice and that is that the information
is on the Jael car website that is our
legal requirement number one we have
satisfied our legal requirement there's
been no question that we've satisfied
our legal requirement
our ethics have all been challenged
because there was a link that wasn't
working on our website the more
important part of that is no one
bothered to point it out apparently
everybody behind me decided that the
website wasn't working but didn't bother
to call miss Shay or me who is in charge
objection okay we are attributing a
motivation to people who are providing
testimony I think it's wildly
inappropriate yes you cannot
cannot concern yourself with their with
their motivation you must simply deal
with what they did or said thank you um
I am in charge of right to nose as
Department counsel I have had no right
to nose for any proposals that are in
front of this board today um the
department I am also receive all
inquiries in that come into the doe info
um my staff doesn't know and this would
have been something that would have come
to me or miss Shay I have not received
any inquiries that there was um any
broken information or not available
information but most importantly we've
complied with the law and that's 541a
and that was our that was Our obligation
uh the department had attempted and
unfortunately sounds like unsuccessfully
to provide an extra layer of information
and that is not does not make it illegal
um so one of the last comments that was
made was um that the rules in front of
you are beyond the scope of the
Department of Education um well the
department of education does not have Ru
making Authority these rules are the
state board rules that's always very
important to notice um the Department of
Education is a unique agency and that
our agency does not have our
commissioner does not have the authority
to promulgate rules our rul making
Authority is the state board um that
does make us unique
um there's been um a lot of discussion
by um several speakers that um Were
Somehow not going to have uh instruction
um and I hate to go back to go the first
half but I think I have to like go back
to the first half rules in order to
point to the places where the rules
actually require instruction which is
the content areas then are tied to the
back half um 3
30618 a says all students have access to
full year full day instruction in person
as required in RSA 1891 and RSA
18924 that's full day full-time
instruction the other piece of this goes
back to school year which is under
30615 each School shall maintain a
calendar provides 180 days of
instruction are the required number of
instructional hours which may be result
in fewer than 180 days so it's very
clear and then it been be it breaks down
to the number of instructional time for
kindergarten elementary schools and for
grades 7 to 12 there's and if that's
tied to the other rule that requires
in-person
instruction
um there was a
concern uh expressed um by one of the
speakers relating to the academic
standards setting forth kind of where we
want kids at certain benchmarks fourth
and eth and 12th grade I would say look
no further than to the legislative
language in 193
e2a Roman numeral 2 which set force that
standards shall cover kindergarten
through 12th grade in cudly F forth the
opportunities to acquire communication
analytical research skills substance of
knowledge expected to be possessed by
students at various grade levels
including the credit requirement
necessary to earn a high school diploma
so this the legislature has said the
academic standards are supposed to be
pegged to certain grade levels which is
what we've done legislature hasn't said
that the academic standards have to
provide a criteria for attainment for
each grade through K through
um there uh
there was a statement that the academic
standards were optional and that we
don't have programs I think if you look
carefully at the the the back half if
you go through each content area um the
con the each start with the same
language that the local school board
shall ensure a development appropriate
and fill in the blank for what the
content area program for each School
consistent with the local competencies
again you have to go back and look at
the definition of program and the rules
22 which defines program as a grouping
of interrelated activities opportunities
and resources designed to implement a
particular goal there's no question that
there's program education instructional
time and that's been done and we've I
think we've beat the dead horse of in
front of that the has to be a
credentialed educator a credential that
is granted by the State Board of
Education instructing the students under
these rules um I'm sure I've missed
something um oh a couple of things
regarding um I think the concern about
uh digital literacy if you go look to
the um
front half again unfortunately the
graduation requirements currently
require half a credit of digital
literacy they have for the last 10 plus
years they've already this is this is
the complaint is actually about
something that's been incurrent uh
law the entire time and if there's any
concern about lack of academic standards
for um rhetoric at this point those
rules don't go into effect for kids
until they enter School two years from
now so I mean it's going to take some
time to get those academic standards
done but I'm hopeful that the department
will and the state board will be able to
approve those in line with the um time
frame set forth in those rules but if
you if you look at these we're really
making very minimal changes and I it's
it's unfortunate that it seems like we
can't read through the the rules in the
front half to allow our our education of
how the back half is supposed to to to
work um and you're getting a little bit
blind I'm happy to answer any questions
in case I miss somebody's point from
earlier that you all um need to have
discussed I have one
question in Miss downing's report there
is a page that shows an increase in
credits required for graduation in the
area of social studies is that due to
the rule or is it due to additions in
the statute there were changes in the
statute that um required additional um
graduation requirements in the in the
area of
civics thank
you representative hacken Phillips thank
you madam chair just a quick question
has the State Board of Education met
since the last legislative oversight
committee meeting and vote on October
29th yes there was a meeting of the
State Board last Thursday and did they
take up the
again hi sorry um Julie Shay um they do
not have to vote on those yet because
the department makes the amended
conditional approval request um they
will be looking at that at the December
meeting and creating a response and then
sending it to the jail
car and in the way in the way your rules
work our conditional approve approval
was due on October 30 not 31st I think
it was
October
November so they were due uh couple of
weeks before the State Board had had a
meeting so in order for us to be at this
meeting we had to get everything
together before the state board
meeting director Mor I'll let attorney
munes explain that director moral if you
could explain that please clarify uh
conditional approvals are a two-stage
process because the rulemaker is rarely
here to request that conditional
approval it's made by their staff that
means the conditional approval goes back
to the agency has to be the language
that was offered by their staff is
reviewed and given approval by
commission or board or department head
office okay
so and yes their their conditional
approval um
deadline was after the deadline for this
gel car meeting so they had to get it in
before the deadline for the Jael car
meeting representative G yes I would
like to could you point out to the the
financial note on the second half what
page is that on I believe it's on page
seven of your final proposal packet it's
within the not the original notice that
was filed with our office with the
initial proposal so the fiscal impact
statement comes from the legislative
budget
assistant and um we include the notice
in all of our final proposal packets and
it starts I'm sorry it starts on page
four of um the FP packet for
202442 and you can see number 10 says
fiscal impact statement and it has a
fiscal impact number and then the fiscal
impact from the
LBA and keep in mind that this analysis
for the LBA is between the proposed rule
rule right
Senator Greg I'm looking for and I have
a question another question I'd like to
uh know what legislation was passed that
requires Civics what what I don't have a
recollection of that
and I I can't find that fiscal note on
page seven I'm
off
18911 instruction in National andate
Civics
Jack yes there's a list in 1A requiring
dedicated class time for civics in
elementary halfe course of the
equivalent in Civics in Middle School
halfe course in Civics in high school a
one-year course in history government
constitutions in new United States and
New Hampshire in high school required
for high school graduation and that
effective
date
yes yes representative Lon September
that is the most recent change in that
statute but I'm not sure it pertains to
that yeah if if I may I think there
might be some confusion here I I might
be able to help um so so if you look at
that uh High School graduation
requirements the list there's 20 credits
is what we had before and we remain with
20 credits we made some
changes but you'll notice that at the
top it we changed the language from
required course of study and credits to
requir
credits for high school
graduation so you still have 20 credits
just like you did before but we
rearrange the
credits so I don't have all the history
of the changes here so I don't know that
I could get you every single thing that
we changed um and there were some
changes that were made at state board
meetings based upon your working group
as well and this is where I corre I yeah
we proposed some changes and then we got
feedback on them and altered them we
were going
to uh reduce the number of open
electives further than we actually end
up doing um and that was on feedback
from uh CTE instructors but we added
um so for example we Chang the
mathematics credits to add a half Credit
in statistics and data analysis right
and reduce it from four required credits
to um three or three and a half do we
um we made an adjustment to the history
the way the the history credits are are
required
um and logic and rhetoric but it's
important to note that those are
credits and to get to one of the points
that was made
before um this is not a requirement to
offer a standalone logic and rhetoric
class this is consistent with the
statutory
um authority to require because the
statute requires that the kids get
credits in in logic and rhetoric we put
that into the High School requirements
not for a standalone course but for
credits just to reemphasize that
legislative
requirement so I don't know if that
helps at all but um Madam chair uh Dr
Downing I think has a perspective on
you because I'm not clear it's very
unclear before we to another person in
the audience you did recognize me and
one of the representatives had a a a
follow on question so I would like to be
recognized thank you we're trying to
answer this this question but but
Senator gray please I moved to approve I
have not heard anything in this
testimony that has changed my opinion uh
from what I had when I walked into the
room so thank you all right thank you we
if someone it has been seconded by
representative
Lynn uh is there someone who can answer
the question about these these credits
to our yes thank you Miss Downing that
would
help if you actually go to my report
page 29 you'll see a direct
comp look it again I am going to have to
respectfully disagree with attorney
Brown over here that the credit
requirements were a result of of changes
in the legislation and if you look at my
chart on page 29 I'll carefully explain
that to you so us and New Hampshire
history has always been offered in our
high schools as one credit what the
board did was separate that now out
specifically to be US history is a half
credit separate New Hampshire history is
a h half credit that was a net change of
zero United States and New Hampshire
government and Civics has always been
offered there is nothing in the RSA in
193e that changed to cause these credit
requirement changes so they decided to
separate out Civics but I want to point
out that in paragraph 1 of 193 e2a which
defines the areas for an adequate
education Civics has always been listed
next to social studies in the
parenthesis Civic has been and continues
to be happening in our high schools and
then they separated out the history
government and Constitution of us and
New Hampshire to one credit again I'm
going to tell you from a high school
perspective in our Us in New Hampshire
government classes the study of the
Constitution has always been there there
has not been a legislative an RSA change
to need that in economics and this is
where I'm going to counteract the
argument from Cher Klein where he
continues to say well they can do it
integr cuz I brought this up at the
State Board of Ed economics has always
been a graduation requirement and when
the first bill passed that required the
in the the direct instruction of
personal finance literacy that Bill said
it may be integrated so therefore many
high schools integrated personal finance
literacy into economics but you can see
what the board has now done is made
personal finance literacy its own
separate half Credit Now that sends a
signal to the field that they can no
longer be integrated because prior we
could the world history Global Studies
or geography has always been there that
is not a legislative change but yet they
have now opt it to a full credit with no
no Clarity to the field about why are we
increasing this to a full credit if
we've already got it in there and then
logic and rhetoric for years well I
wouldn't say years last few years logic
and rhetoric has been part of Part B of
e2a and it the RSA clearly says there
that it will be integrated in the above
academic areas of paragraph one but yet
now we've imposed a half credit I have
to refute the public claim that was made
here this today that these credit
changes were due to RSA changes that is
not correct and I do want to speak
question Mr Downey not a not an
accusation the question was is that due
to legislative changes no it's not thank
you
okay I would like to speak to the motion
well I I'll let the I'll let the person
who made the motion speak to his motion
Senator gray have you you spoke to the
motion do you wish just continue pretty
much I've said all I want except that
that you know I believe that the process
has been followed and tried to be
followed correctly and that I am ready
to vote on this issue all right thank
you Senator Whitley thank you madam
chair um I think you know what's at
stake here which has been made very
clear is that we're talking about the
quality of our public education in New
Hampshire and that's what's at stake
here you know I'm a mom I have a fifth
grader I have a deep deep interest in
making Mak sure that my son's education
is as high quality as possible of course
for every child in my district in the
state that's what's at stake here the
quality of our public education should
not be a partisan issue it shouldn't
which is why it was it was pretty
unfortunate that first vote was a
partisan vote because it shouldn't be
the quality of our public education has
nothing to do with politics it is the
foundation of our democracy it's a
constitutional requirement in the state
of New Hampshire there has been
countless litigation defining what is a
adequate education that's what's at
stake here this should not be about
politics yet we seem to be going in a
direction we where we are
ignoring the vast majority of our
Educators our administrators our parents
all whom have major major concerns with
these rules and I deeply respect our
attorneys was uh that serve the J car I
deeply respect them and also it is Our
obligation as elected officials to
determine and make an analysis about the
public interest and that's what we were
doing
here so I I want to clearly State for
the record that based on the volume of
testimony we have received both today
and over the course of almost many years
now that there are four bases for an
objection and that is that those are
more bases than I have ever seen as a
member of Ja car as both a member for
the past four years an attorney who's to
practice in front of Jael car I have
never seen such a substantial solid
basis for objection of any rules I
haven't and there are four I'm look I'm
specifically um referencing our Jal car
rules one the these rules should be
objected to we should all be voting
against the approval because these rules
clearly go beyond agency Authority
that's under part
401 another basis for objection part 402
these rules are clearly con uh contrary
to legislative intent that's part 402
part 403 these rules are clearly
contrary to the public interest and in
my opinion this is the strongest basis
for an objection and then four part 404
there's there is a substantial impact
fiscal impact on these rules it's on
it's it's undeniable and it has not been
recognized in the fiscal impact
statement we have not fully explored
this I feel like this is a dereliction
of our duty to our uh uh constituents
without sufficiently exploring this so
there so based on that I will be voting
against the approval and I really
encourage all of us to take a step back
to take a beat to not make this a
political vote send a message to the
state and to uh our constituents that
public education is not a political
issue to take a step back and listen to
our Educators listen to our parents
listen to our administrators and vote
against this approval and move towards
an objection so we can get this right
Thank you madam chair thank you any
other comments representative hacken
Phillips thank you madam chair um so yes
I agree with Senator Whitley's um
remarks I just wanted to make two notes
there was there was a passing thought
earlier today and testimony that the
public and the
legislature um would need to submit a
right to no request in order to get
timely and accurate information about
the rul making process um that we have
we are reviewing today uh and the
absence of that was suggested as that
there wasn't really a need for it so I
would just like to check mark that as
being um concerning that the legislature
or the public would need to file
official right to no request in order to
receive the information in a timely
basis that we're reviewing today
second is that this there's this
insistence that there's no confusion
because of you know the new front half
of the rules that we just approved
clearly connect and explain the back
half of the rules and uh you know you
can find the clarification of the front
half by looking at the back half and
vice versa and I think that's just a
very spur
position given the testimony we've heard
over and over again that it's not clear
that there are vague terms and that um
the rules the front half and back half
are not clearly defined and do not give
districts clear um marching orders so I
think um again this is concerning um i'
just like to pause and go back to the
RSA 139
e2a
concerns um it seems to me that the
State Board shall not according to RSA
193 e2a Roman numeral 4C the State Board
shall not recommend any existing
academic standards and shall not approve
any new academic standards without prior
review and recommendation of the
legislative oversight committee
established in RSA 193 ca2 and um that
did go in effect August of 2023 so uh
while I do thank the commissioner uh the
director for for providing the
explanation of how conditional approvals
work I think the procedural safeguards
in law under this Clause require
specific processes in sequential order
to be undertaken with for due process
and fair notice through our public
meetings to be upheld so what we see
from the timeline leading up to today is
that the department has failed to First
participate in meaningful public
hearings second provide evidence of
incorporating the committee's feedback
when there were closed door meetings by
some members of the committee but not
all and there being no public meeting uh
or an opportunity for the other members
of the legislative oversight committee
to ask their questions of the
department three uh there was no
provision of appropriate materials or
documents for review by the members of
the committee or the public during those
public meetings by the committee and
four uh there i' just like to clarify
there's General confusion over what the
actual language of the proposed rules or
changes to the rules for that definition
of educator were under consideration at
the time of the committee's vote so um
that committee did review and recommend
um this like very vague statement uh for
their conditional approval but again
that was out of order and in defiance of
legislative intent there remains
important questions whether the state
board has subsequently approved the
committee's final recommendation and
from what I understand they have not and
further question is whether
the committee's final recommendation can
be valued when the proposed rules were
never put into writing before the
committee's final recommendation vote
for the final question is whether the
department of education's rul making
process for the proposed 306 rules
effectively bypass the meeting's
meaningful participation of the
legislative oversight committee and
furthermore their feedback so for on
that basis alone Madam chair um I cannot
vote affirmatively I'm not voting today
but if I were voting I wouldn't be able
to support the motion thank you thank
you anyone else CH I request a roll
call certainly that makes
sense represen Vera yes um these are the
things that
are concerning to
me in that there's no fiscal impact to
these
rules yet I don't know how that analysis
was done and it's something that I'm
going to dig further into because to me
when we have a school board member
saying that there is going to be a
fiscal impact that seems odd to me cuz I
would think that a school district now
maybe they are out of
the
calculation of a of a fiscal note but
that's important and the school
districts are going to get an impact
that's a downshifting of cost to the
districts and I don't know if that's
going to happen and I think it's
important to know that which is why I'm
going to be voting
against um this motion furthermore um I
think that if this occurs it is an
erosion of trust because the trust the
the citizens of New Hampshire trust us
to do what's best for them and I do not
think we're doing that
today thank you Senator
gray um there was a discussion of
parship in this thing we've got the the
Board of
Education nonpartisan we've got our own
nonpartisan I don't understand why
someone would think that our
vote is based on input from people who
are partisan because we've taken the
input from the Board of Education we've
taken the input from the Department of
Education we've taking the input from
the staff my vote was not partisan it
was based on those recommendations of
the people that we
entrust with that
you director arer
house I know I'm a little bit new to the
scene and some people here know me some
people don't I just want to point
something out I think some very nice
things have been said about ol staff and
Os attorneys today by the Senators on
both sides of the aisle uh one thing I
do want to make clear and this was
brought up at the beginning of the
meeting is that ol staff received Miss
downing's written testimony this morning
and we have not done a comprehensive
legal analysis of it so we have reviewed
everything that came prior to this but
we have not looked at this and I just
want to make sure that the Comm is aware
of that before they make any decisions
thank
you m me also on uh regarding the fiscal
impact statements that is um the purview
of the LBA um
should should the the intent of the
legislature to be to um beef up those
fiscal impact statements or make them
different or make the review different
our office would be happy to work with
the LBA because those phal impact
statements do come to us and we do
review them and we do sometimes send
them back to the LBA for Corrections um
but that process is the LBA process we
are happy to help with that yes yes by
no means did my comment have any
reflection on your office it is I just
want to understand it from myself and I
will go speak with them directly and if
something should come up I will be glad
to let you know yes and I will mention
that I'm confused why people are worried
about the fiscal impact when the same
people were testifying that these rules
would weaken the requirements
which I don't understand why that would
wouldn't decrease the cost so uh I which
most people are much less worried about
than cost
increases all right thank you
representative Schmidt you wish to say
something I wish to say that the point
needs to be understood by everybody
listening that is who is going to pay
the
costs constitutions was States and was
pointed out as a basis of the clera
decision the interpretation was that the
word cherish meant fiscal responsibility
of the state to provide an ad adequate
education
but to the degree that these rules
possibly will push
costs off on to property taxpayers that
ain't the state thank you representative
Schmid thank you so I will be voting no
as
well all right the motion is to accept
the
rules Representative groa no
representative Lon yes representative
Lynn yes representative Schmidt
no Senator gray for Senator Lang yes
Senator chandley
no Brook Zone duet for Senator in this
yes yes okay a senator Ward
yes Senator Whitley
no and I will vote Yes and the rule is
thank you all for
coming director moral thank you uh I'd
like to
make one statement for the benefit of
the public uh when attorney Brown was
testifying she indicated the lack of uh
comments substantive comments by our
staff which is absolutely true but she
equated that with uh staff suggesting
approval to the committee that is C not
the case it's not our job to indicate
whether rule should be objected to or
um Board of dental examiners
representative Schmidt has moved to
postponed second second by
representative Lon those in favor I
opposed
thank
you
um
lovely
fertilizers yes um 2024 143 fertilizers
agriculture
1100 um there are a ton of editorial
comments but I won't spend any time on
those all of those can be addressed at
adoption um the main reason why this
proposal is not on the consent agenda is
because the enim rules just expired on
October
27th and um there are two fees that are
included in the rule there is one fee
that is set by the rule itself there is
another fee that is set in statute so
the uh one that's set in statute is in
RSA
4314 and that's the $75 registration fee
but the other fee is set by by the rule
and you'll see that on page 13 of your
packet and that's an agriculture
1106 that fee is an inspection fee of 20
cents a ton with a minimum of
$5 and uh like I said the rules expired
the interim rules just expired on
October 27th so you may have some
questions for the agency of whether or
not they've collected that fee that's
set in the rule and not in the statute
no turn push till the red light comes
red light okay um Patricia Benner
legislative coordinator for the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food would you please speak into the
microphones sure I'm sorry close you
have speak into not sorry I was hearing
a lot of reverberation before so was
he's got aot trying to spare everyone's
ears
um Patricia Benner legislative
coordinator for the Department of
Agriculture markets and food um and I
would assume that to answer that
question um there has been a lapse the
original rule um that expired on 20 uh
1027 was an interim Rule and so
therefore um because even though it was
in the process
um they expired um so we're you know
there's a couple of weeks lag
unfortunately there was um an early
payment of $15 that was uh went through
through however
um that was the only one that that um in
yes good than anyone have any comments
questions
motions Senator gray moves to approve
any
discussion all
opposed I'm glad you've approved it
frame all
right um HHS has two interim
rules uh yes um interim rule 11 and 12
um the first has to do with the
distribution and dispersement of support
there may be a question about how the
agency has been
enforcing uh the distribution and
dispersement of support payments without
rules there are some federal regulations
regarding this topic however the rules
are much more specific than the Federal
Regulations so it's hard to um rely
solely on those Federal
Regulations yes thank
you good afternoon Alison radme the
administrator for for the rules unit at
Services good afternoon my name is Lisa
dekowski and I am the bureau chief for
the Bureau of Child Support Services
with the Department of Health and Human
Services Division of economic
stability and what have you done for the
last uh two months while your rules were
expired uh thank you madam chair for the
question um our agency has continued to
uh distribute and uh disperse child
support payments that we have received
over these last uh period of time that
the rule has expired naturally our
program has a duty to the families that
we are serving to ensure that not only
are the payments that we are collecting
on behalf of um parents who are ordered
by the court to pay support but we also
have an obligation to ensure that those
payments are dispersed to the families
um that are rightfully
those payments and uh under the uh
Federal uh law of the Social Security
Act uh the child support program uh
certainly wants to be able to continue
that we maintain uh the economic uh and
income supports for the families that
we're currently serving um so it would
have been um perhaps more detrimental
had we not been able to provide These
funds to the families that we're
currently serving um to speak to to the
comment about um the federal law not
being as uh specific um as the current
rule uh is um there are also uh the
federal law clearly provides States
child support programs
uh uh the distribution rules for child
support cases in addition to that the
Federal Regulation
also clearly um explain how the
distribution of child support payments
in state agency should be um dispersed
and uh also our current federal our
currently federally approved automated
system is programmed accordingly to be
able to disperse those payments to
families um as they are received in a
timely fashion um and so uh with that we
have um continued to provide that
service under these circumstances and we
certainly have initiated uh uh quick and
fast uh resolutions to try to ensure
that the rules um uh are are quickly in
place um and that we're not in this
situation again thank
you well thank you for that ex
explanation if the federal laws are that
detailed why do we need these rules
anyway thank you madam chair it's a it's
a great question um there are some
options that states have and some states
have specific uh fees or interests that
they charge in although we don't have
specific fees um there are options to
how we would distribute certain types of
payments based towards aares so the the
laws allow uh the rules allow
the um us to be able to clarify how we
are currently providing for that here in
New Hampshire thank you all right any
rules the expired rules and which are
the same as these interim rules yes yes
thank you but the question was what have
you been doing during the period when
the rules were
expired thank you for the question um
represent we have continued to
distribute money as we have received
them as they had been
uh documented in the existing rules so
we have continued business as usual to
support the income for the families and
for the paying parents that we are
serving yes I would like to mention that
for the last 10 years at least it has
been explicitly illegal to enforce
expired rules so you're very L very
lucky that no one has
complained because they would be a able
Authority
so any other questions comments move to
approve second by representative Lon
discussion those in favor I I
opposed all
right the lottery
intercept um so this interm rule
like the previous one has been filed to
minimize the time between the expiration
of the effective Rule and the subsequent
read-option this rule um has been
expired since July 22nd of this year um
and this one also has uh a state statute
that authorizes the department to
intercept this money along with the
federal Authority but once again there
may be a question about how the program
has been
collecting and intercepting that money
without rules because it's the rules
is thank you
um similarly um to what I had just
previously stated the program has
continued um to under the authority of
our uh Social Security Act on behalf of
the child support program in accordance
with the state law um in addition to um
the uh New Hampshire lottery
commission's uh rule related to the
suspension due to child support as well
as our existing memorandum of
understanding with the uh Lottery
Commission uh to continue to operate
under uh the uh General procedures and
policies that we always have operated
under with relation to this rule um
again uh you know the duty of the child
support program is to ensure that we are
collecting and enforcing orders of
support under the uh title 4D of the
Social Security Act in compliance with
our federal and um uh regulations to
ensure that parents are receiving income
and are in compliance with their um
orders for child support uh recognize
that um uh Madam chair your point was
very well taken of earlier and uh
certainly the department and uh my our
Bureau is taking um expedient action to
address these issues um moving forward
how many Lottery uh intercepts do you
handled is is it a DA weekly occurrence
or is it
rare it is sporadic I I don't have the
total numbers uh like on a daily or a
monthly basis prepared for me
today
okay any other questions
comments move to approval by Senator
gray seconded by represent Lan who got a
little bit ahead Senator
Ward discussion those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very much
and I'm glad you at least acting on your
expired
rules and I think we will not dis
discuss the other business sorry about
that cancellation a continued meeting
there is no continued meeting in
December there is just one thing this is
Mike morals last Jael car just want to
okay it's been my pleasure and privilege
to work for the committee for all these
years um I think this is a wonderful
iteration of the committee and I hope
that all of you that are coming back
come back here
yes um thank you
the house members who have been
reelected which is all of us are like
very likely to be appointed very quickly
I Senator Lang is responsible for the
Senate doing the same we do have a
December meeting after the
uh the the new house and new Senate have
been organized we do not have a
continued meeting meeting because we do
need one Senator at least so that we
have a quum so that the chair can be
elected can so the the chair can be
elected and appoint all right thank you
all for
are